dude welcome to the podcast i looks like
i've got a pope hat on
when you do that with my beanie
i just kind of unfolded it and then i
was the pope
uh welcome everybody defying the odds
you know i turned on the news this
morning and they're like
issue podcasts ethan neil klein wouldn't
dare show their faces again
and i was like you know what i'm gonna
prove them wrong turn off the power
came down here started the podcast what
was that like good morning america or
it was uh yeah it was good morning
america
yeah it was mainstream it was on like
channel two whatever that is nationally
syndicated
today we have with us the uh
hassan [ __ ] a twitch streamer i would
even venture to say
the most popular twitch streamer that
doesn't play games he's a progressive
he plays a little plays a little games
we learned
but i don't think that's what he's known
for no but he's a progressive
commentator and um i really find him
interesting because like i feel like the
space is so predominantly
uh occupied by conservative voices i
find it really cool that
there's a progressive who's will who's
able to flourish
in this space um so
so i think it's interesting i think he's
an interesting guest so i'm happy to
have him on hassan [ __ ]
also today teddy fresh release is
out new summer drop
sorry and including the anxiety shirt
that
everybody can't wait to get their hands
on mm-hmm
you love it you hate it whatever you
think about the shirt
100 oh thank you uh the president is a
fan of
this shirt i said i love it i heard you
the first time donald and i appreciated
it then too
look how happy and beautiful they are
because they're wearing teddy fresh
and you could be that happy and
beautiful too by going to teddyfresh.com
look at all these beautiful new items
color block quilted jacket
cute af hoodie we got some jewelry and
of course
everybody's favorite shirt i have
crippling anxiety
which whether if you love it or you hate
it
whatever you think about this shirt 100
of the profits are being
donated to mental health america
so it's a win-win here on the h3 podcast
but there's so much more to see
including the beanies which are finally
back in stock which have been sold out
forever
and we need members to join right now
chris hanson is literally investigating
zach we learned in the last episode
and we don't know what he's going to
uncover all i know is that i need
young zach and i can't allow anything to
happen to him he's way too important
he's way too
uh sweet of a soul so hit that join
membership
become a member for early access no ads
or i mean could cr is zach's gonna be
having a seat
on have a seat with chris hanson none of
us want that
anyway so let us continue on
with our our interview with hassan
[ __ ] i have to say hassan first of all
thank you for
joining us very glad to have you with us
i've noticed that you are occupying a
very unique space
in the internet landscape whereas
twitch and the internet at large
seem a lot of like young conservatives
have found voices in communities
and but but not but there's not many
people like you who are kind of uh
leading uh liberal communities i don't
know do you use the word liberal i'm not
even sure how to describe it
but like left yeah i wouldn't even
consider
i don't i don't consider myself a
liberal but in the american political
lexicon i guess like i'm
super liberal that's what they uh that's
what americans think uh
liberalism is like the more the more
left you are the more liberal you are
even though there is a genuine
distinction between the leftist and the
liberal but
yeah i'm i'm uh progressive i guess
that's yeah
i like progressive yeah it's who
wouldn't want to be progressive it's in
the name
we're progressing progress well that's
why like early stage
classical liberals who like wanted to
rebrand
like dave rubin for example who now are
very openly on the right and like
everyone knows it
they originally tried to say like
they're the real progressives
and that uh the people who brand
themselves as progressives people like
myself
they were actually regressive regressive
yeah but it didn't work so now dave
rubin gets a lot of money from you know
just pager university and numerous other
republican think tanks and whatnot so
now he's just openly
a libertarian as he calls himself
so you've got this community of
progressives which
why is it first of all that we don't see
more
more people like you when there's just
there's tons of communities and people
doing uh conservative movements why is
it that this progressive thing
on the internet is so rare do you have
an opinion on that um
i think that there's a lot of liberals
in mainstream media
like a lot of people who brand
themselves as progressive but aren't
really all that progressive
or will use like the aesthetics of
progressive politics
to weaponize even in some instances
against their political opponents
whether that be
right wingers or even members on the
left like they kept saying burning bros
are sexist
and racist and stuff like that um those
people occupy a gigantic space in media
and uh because of that there there
hasn't really been
a need for alternative
uh more independent content creators
that also
uh promote that kind of commentary
whereas
i feel like with fox news you have fox
news or with
am radio you have uh radio broadcasters
but then beyond that
there aren't that many um real
conservatives
uh in in represented in media mainstream
media specifically that's why there's a
lot more
people out there on the internet doing
their own thing as like independent
content creators
uh on the right whereas on the left you
don't really see that
and then the most significant reason is
because money
um there are numerous uh
there are numerous republican or even
alt-lite or even just like you know
centrist
uh commentators on the internet that are
pretty fairly established in the right
as well uh
that get money from donors
get money from uh those who own capital
and they'll just uh they'll just keep
funding these programs i mean
you see this in mainstream media as well
with like something like the federalist
which is a right-wing publication we
still don't know who funds them
it's basically a meme at this point in
like left twitter or
uh you know political twitter no one
knows who funds the federalist
but it's it's basically like a jobs
program for
republican fail sons that get
republicans jobs over and over again
yeah
like conservative fail sons who just
keep failing outwards
and that kind of that kind of money
doesn't exist for the left because
the left is one disjointed disoriented
and also too does not have the same kind
of money
that uh that right-wing publications
have because
they're speaking out against the rich
pretty openly
you know so the wealthy are not going to
exactly go out of their way to fund you
if you're constantly like
i don't think billionaires should exist
that kind of wealth accumulation is a
systemic problem
so you think maybe that's where the
progressives are even
distinct from what would be considered
liberalism because
like you said you see liberalism a lot
in mainstream media but
but progressivism which is being not
funded to the same degree
is probably it's just a matter of money
and and the interest of people who have
money
is what you think yeah i i think these
ideas are definitely very popular
um and they're even popular in circles
that you would not expect them to be
popular in
if i were to spend 15 minutes talking to
a random person who's apolitical about
the way that um
the way that wealth accumulates in this
country they would probably
at the end of that 15 minutes recognize
yeah you know what it is kind of
it is how this system works it's pretty
simple
wealthy people make a lot of money and
they set the rules
in a way that uh that continues their
success
and uh there are problems associated
with that
um and uh usually people who don't have
that kind of wealth who
are destined to a lifetime of working
meaningless jobs or menial jobs they
will never
achieve that level of wealth and success
even though it's portrayed to them or
even though it's sold to them as though
they will one day become
uh millionaires or billionaires even
though we
every single one of us no matter how
much money we make and
now with twitch i definitely make a
decent amount of money a month
um and i'm sure you guys do as well we
are way closer
we're infinitely closer to homelessness
than we are to becoming the next
jeff bezos as a matter of fact i think
even elon musk is closer to
becoming homeless than he is to becoming
jeff bezos
like it's crazy it's a crazy uh
so but like no and i kind of wealth is
unimaginable
it really is bezos is a rich mother dude
but i'll say this
so what is it then like what is the
ultimate goal let's say of of
progressivism you say billionaire
shouldn't exist do you really mean that
there should be
no billionaires because it's kind of the
antithesis
of what the american dream
the whole ethos of what america is right
i mean what what really can you do when
you say
i don't want i don't think billionaires
should exist
i mean what does that mean so i think
that
the existence of billionaires is a
product of wealth accumulation
and a lack of wealth redistribution
in all of our economies but
the way that for example sweden works or
norway works they have
more billionaires per capita than the
united states
fun fact that most people neglect to
mention so
like i'm not crazy i'm not saying you
know just go out in the streets and like
rip billionaires from their homes and
and forcibly distribute redistribute
their wealth like that
that's some people advocate for that but
those people are in the margins and
you know it's it's something that you
should just laugh at and move on
what i'm saying is we should move
towards a sweden
style economy or a norway style economy
which would be a social democracy
with robust social safety nets and
protections for
workers like higher unionization rates a
lot of these countries have
nearly full unionization rates or
they have um almost their entire labor
force
under contracts so that even if they are
not a part of a union they're still
protected
by that industry's union-backed
negotiations
in america that number is 11 in a
country like finland
the last time i looked at this i think
it was like around
90 percent or it just it just swings
around like 80 to 90 percent
so that's a huge problem for workers in
this country
and i think that you know uh ideas like
american the american dream which is
just the dream
unfortunately or this notion that like
we're all going to become millionaires
one day
and and meritocracy even is a very
successful way
of making people feel
like as long as they put their heads
down
and work and listen to their managers
listen to their bosses
and don't really ask for more then one
day they too
can succeed and while there are fringe
cases of people actually succeeding
that doesn't mean that uh it's going to
happen for the overwhelming majority of
people that are just a part of the
working class
every day average so joe's
if there's more billionaires per capita
in sweden how is it that
so this expression because you said
earlier you don't think billionaires
should exist but
i guess maybe that's that's that's
hyperbolic you don't
literally mean that okay
so do i think that if it was possible
for billionaires to exist while
simultaneously eradicating homelessness
and even making sure that the gigantic
wealth disparity that currently
exists in the global south or in
developing nations
uh if we eradicated all of that and we
still had billionaires
then hell yeah i see you have a lot of
bernie sanders swag in the background
is that your guy oh i love bernie yeah
for sure
i love bernie too yeah bernie was uh
that was a beautiful dream that was kind
of an american dream that died there it
almost came true didn't it
yeah i mean it was a very long shot
i i always told the people that watch me
like look
this is very likely not going to happen
i i think that it is definitely a long
shot regardless of
how successful he was or how popular he
is
how popular his policies are like
medicare for all for example
regardless of all that i i just always
was skeptical because i just assumed
that
every institution every legitimate
institution legacy publishers all that
were
would do everything they can to at the
very least
um at the very least make it seem like
he was bad
you know what i mean well he came so
close and then
it was kind of almost bizarre how joe
biden
seemed out like he was done
and then all of a sudden what was it
like north carolina
was just this total shift no south
carolina oh south carolina um
yeah the south carolina primary is
actually pretty significant in the
democratic primaries as a whole
it's it's a very weird process that we
have in the democratic primaries where
the first state you look at is iowa they
pride themselves on being the first
state and they have a caucus system
which is really awful i'm not going to
get into it
it's a super outdated way of doing it uh
things and it's undemocratic regardless
but it's basically iowa which is uh
92 white so not reflective of the rest
of the united states at all
that that really is like the big
uh the first big race and then it's
nevada
which is very diverse and definitely
more representative of the
the demographics of the united states
and then you move oh
sorry iowa and then um wait i'm messing
it up
it's iowa new hampshire and then nevada
sorry and new hampshire is very white as
well
and then nevada and then you get to you
get to south carolina
in south carolina especially on the
democratic
side the the south carolina voter
profile
for the democratic party is super
unrepresented
uh unrepresentative of the uh of the
rest of the american demographics as
well
so so we have like a very so we have a
very
interesting way of doing things in the
democratic par uh
party but the south carolina the south
carolina primary is
uh the most important one because it is
predominantly overwhelmingly black and
the black voting bloc is the most
significant voting bloc
that most consistently and reliably
votes democratic in the generals
so uh for example representative jim
clyburn is regarded as the king maker
because of that uh anyone who
any anyone who he endorses ends up
becoming the president
um so that's how joe biden really won he
he failed disastrously in
the first three competitions and it
seemed like he was out but he kept
saying you know wait till south carolina
wait till south carolina
and it was expected that he was going to
win south carolina for sure
no matter what right um because
uh people wanted to vote for him in
south carolina he always looked
to be polling by a wide margin in south
carolina and then
and then when he did win there was a
three-day streak of just
non-stop coverage the underdog is back
joe biden this guy who's been in
politics for like
50 years and it was obama's vice
president
was now the underdog and uh just
and see a sea of endless positive
coverage
about joe biden's chances followed up by
every virtually every single incumbent
that was
in the race that still had a shot or not
incumbent sorry virtually every single
other primary
opponent that had a shot dropping out
and endorsing it before super tuesday
which then really stacked the deck
against bernie sanders
and uh elizabeth warren staying in the
race as well uh
also uh sullied the progressive
base by separating the progressive base
and that's how you got uh joe biden
victory after victory and even states in
most states that he
not he hadn't even been to yet in
california he lost but
he didn't even have an office like he
had one office that was uh padlocked
that no one had even that no one had
even stepped into in months
he went to virginia once and he won in
overwhelming numbers
and part of that is because people were
aware of him and they wanted a safe
choice and the media kept portraying him
as the safe choice and the one that will
beat
donald trump well um let me ask you as a
as a progressive do you think do you
think that bernie sanders could beat
trump and do you think defeating trump
is more important than putting out a
progressive that may
lose where i think joe has a pretty
solid chance now
it looks like of of defeating trump
what do you think is more important a
bernie
a risky bernie or a solid joe
well that's the thing i don't think
bernie is risky
i don't think bernie was risky at all
it's
it's how they were portraying bernie
that made him risky i mean think about
it
but that makes sense well
but then the problem there is not
necessarily bernie sanders
being a risky candidate in and of itself
that's true but
rather the media's unwillingness to
cover him yeah yeah but it's still a
matter but that's still you can't ignore
that right
because just imagine just imagine his
own
people like he can't even galvanize
his own side of the aisle because of all
these
issues of of wealth and equality uh you
know wealth equality
so like just imagine how stacked that we
would be against him
ultimately if with both
both sides of interested wealth uh
stacked against bernie it would have
been
i mean how could you overcome that that
would be incredible
you know i i i don't disagree with you i
think that's a legitimate fear
that i had if bernie was to become the
candidate
even though that was a long shot i was
legitimately concerned with like
all of these liberal outlets all of a
sudden attacking
the democratic candidate yeah or even
uh fighting against them in a similar
capacity to how
uh jeremy corbyn had a sea of coverage
anti-jeremy corbin coverage and
anti-labor party coverage
by all accounts of the media with only
the guardian
endorsing him but endorsing him with
concern
um meanwhile the tories were
openly both anti-semitic and racist
and and horrible they they put up a
statue of nancy
store who once uh famously said that
hitler had the right idea about jews in
the middle of all of this
in the middle of all of this uh jeremy
corbyn has anti-semitic coverage
the tories the conservative party
literally
put up a statue of a woman who said that
uh
and and they were still like nope jeremy
corbyn is anti-semitic
and that is in my opinion that is
definitely
uh people who are in positions of power
trying to
protect their their bottom line trying
to protect
the the current financial situation that
they're in um it's understandable that's
what the purpose of the media is that's
what the purpose of all of these like
legitimate institutions are
in a way it's to preserve order right
because if you were to append the entire
system then
that could be a little chaotic and it
definitely wouldn't be great for
uh people in positions of power who have
made a lot of money off the
uh status quo so
the similar thing would definitely could
definitely happen to bernie sanders as
well and i was
fearful of that but what do you but like
are you so going to support
joe now that he's nominated like where's
your yeah
so my opinion is look i'm very critical
i'm very critical of joe i i've been
very critical of him
i was very i was even critical of the
obama administration when
he was president and um
obviously he's still infinitely better
than donald trump so i'm not gonna
lie to people for a uh
like or my personal opinion
uh to preserve my personal opinion or
like to to
i'm just not going to lie to you that's
what i've been telling people whenever
they ask me like
well you know do you think joe is better
than trump like of course joe biden is
better than donald trump
very few people are worse than him i
think i think people take that from that
statement for granted right
because i hear a lot of people who
identify as progressive
actually i don't even know because
somehow there's a lot of people that
both like
bernie and trump and that to me is
interesting because i guess they just
both kind of like the outliers change
like a radical change
yeah so a lot of people are like well
bernie lost so i'm not going to support
biden
so when you say that that's insane
i agree that that's insane well it
doesn't make sense to me
actually the only way that it makes
sense i think it's a lot of people who
are not
super politically active or necessarily
understand the diff
who they are but they just like that
they're outlier candidates
that they represent some kind of
different change but when you say a
statement like
joe is infinitely better than trump what
do you mean by that
because i don't want to take that
statement for granted here okay
so what i mean by that is
even though there might be marginal
differences between joe biden and donald
trump on certain matters where the
democratic and republican party
always seem to find bipartisan consensus
like american foreign policy or even
tax cuts for the wealthy for the most
part which is something that even barack
obama
uh pushed forward at a time when
he didn't need to um outside of that
outside of those uh marginal differences
there are gigantic differences like in
the way
that uh competent administration
would handle something like the
coronavirus pandemic or
um i just don't think that joe biden is
going to be sending
like federal shock troops like the
gestapo
into portland and democratic cities
because uh he wants to violently squash
these uh
overall major overwhelmingly uh
a peaceful and in some instances not as
peaceful
protests um demonstrated by
moms and veterans and you know what i
mean and dads and
just the old people along with this like
boogie man of antifa
i i think that joe biden wouldn't do
that and that
is is a significant difference i think
between
someone like donald trump and someone
like joe biden so
what i mean by that is marginal
differences in policy
lead to drastically different outcomes
when it comes to the lives of millions
of americans
a great example of this for example is
like under barack obama
ice deportation still continued uh
nearly three million people were
deported
right um but under donald trump
uh donald trump changed the direction
of ice uh specifically the enforcement
removal like the the removal operations
branch of ice
which is what we know as ice popularly
um he changed a rule so that
non-violent non-criminal offenders were
considered
uh we're considered for immediate
deportation
like that's crazy to me if you've been
here
for 20 years you've never broken a law
and you're overall like a law-abiding
abuela
and you cross the border with your with
your kids in tow
i think it is a horrifically inhumane
thing to do
to just come into your house lie to get
into your house which is what ice does
in a lot of instances
they don't really have an actual warrant
what what do you mean they
lie oh um so this is one of the famous
things that ice does
uh which is why the aclu and numerous
other organizations that deal with ice
always tell immigrants and if there are
any undocumented immigrants listening to
this podcast
you never ever ever need to open the
door to ice
never do that unless they have an arrest
warrant
and in which case they can break in if
you don't open the door
and make sure that they slide the actual
arrest warrant
underneath the door really because they
will portray themselves as police
officers when technically they're not
and they will they will openly lie to
you to be able to get
access into your home what are they
allowed to
lie and say like what do they say like
we have a warrant you have to open
um they'll say they have a uh they don't
have like an actual arrest warrant
but they they'll show a federal decree
like a piece of paper
that looks official to say like this
allows me to come into your home and
arrest you
that's a lie they also don't have to
tell you they don't have to tell you
that they're not
literal cops unless you ask them who is
at my door
why are you here are you a police
officer they can
they wear they wear branded gear that
says they're police and they're federal
agents
but technically they don't have the same
kind of jurisdiction that police
officers do
unless you are in what the aclu
considers to be a constitution free zone
100 miles in from every border and every
sea line
that's a totally separate conversation
though but more often than not
in the overwhelming majority of ice
deportations especially if they are
entering the home of someone who is
undocumented but
hasn't had any like significant felony
offenses otherwise
um you don't have to open your door to
ice unless they show you a
valid real arrest warrant that's gotta
be so stressful
just thinking to be in that position to
even have to make sense of that
situation at that moment
oh yeah yeah and clearly like yeah you
would open the door
most likely and also what happens if you
don't open the door do they come back
like next week um
they'll just they'll just move on to
someone else usually
but um but they can come back if they
suspect you of
like actually committing a crime that's
beyond just like border crossing
or avoiding uh deportation
in that in that circumstance they could
technically go to a judge and try to get
an arrest warrant but
um again that's like that's proper
protocol
but uh they don't usually have to follow
proper protocol they can just come in
and be like i'm a cop
open the door please we need to have a
conversation with you
or you know whatever they obviously say
to get in obviously the counter argument
to that is just well they broke the law
they came into the country illegally why
shouldn't they be deported i mean
that just makes sense it's like you know
you came in you broke the law
so you don't belong here right i mean i
mean that seems pretty cut and dry
yeah um i don't substitute morality for
legality plenty of unjust laws exist
currently and plenty of unjust laws have
existed throughout history
slavery is a great example of that where
it was
you know it was a violation of the law
yeah but how are you unpleasant
i mean don't you believe in that we
should have some kind of border
do i how is it unjust yeah i mean like
technically speaking i mean
like we have a border and we have uh
immigration law right
so mm-hmm and what about yeah
i think that was brought here with a
family
and now yeah they've already been here
20 years and they
have started a whole life here so
if you're saying i'm just playing
devil's advocate first of all
if you're saying there's a family that
comes and has a kid so the kid's a
citizen right because he was born in the
u.s
and then they can deport the parents but
not the kid right
they can deport the parents and not the
kid yes and they do deport the parents
and not the kid the kid is a
natural born u.s citizen which is
actually something that trump's
administration
uh also wants to remove as well with
approaching those anchor babies
yeah make her babies i love that i'm an
anchor baby myself
um so so as
i mean sure yeah i could see that being
extremely uh problematic like especially
when you're dealing
so what would happen if ice came and you
have like a two-year-old
does the kid stay or does the kid get
deported because they can't deport a u.s
citizen
no they they don't deport the kid so so
that's actually where the child
separation stuff comes from too
uh in part where if you have a child
and you are the sole uh a person
responsible for a child and you are an
undocumented citizen and they arrest you
then
the kid gets also put into the system
and uh oftentimes in like horrific
conditions too which is what was the big
controversy around like child separation
um they'll just
they'll just process you as a kid and
if there are no immediate family members
that come in
and uh take you out of the processing
take you out of one of these child
detention centers where you're in
um then then you're you're
pushed forward through the system into a
foster care program
um so one of the most horrific things
that the trump administration did
actually this is another
one but very dark fact not so fun is
um they used
anyone who would come in to collect the
children
that uh were in processing in child
detention centers
as an opportunity to further prosecute
additional family members
who are also undocumented which of
course obviously
deters family members from collecting
their
uh relatives their immediate relatives
from processing if they themselves are
undocumented
because then you have to give up your
address and your immigration status
for the federal authorities to be able
to come in and and
take this like two-year-old
three-year-old ten-year-old out of
a detention center where they're
genuinely being tortured i mean this is
a form of torture no matter what you
yeah
no matter what you believe this is
horrifically inhumane
yeah um and uh the trump administration
was doing that
i totally yeah i agree i mean separate
leaving a kid into foster care and
separating their parents is totally
inhumane but then like so
so the the argument right goes a step
further they say
well you know these drastic measures
are necessary because it prevents people
from coming over the border
having sex getting pregnant real fast
and then it's like oh we're all american
citizens now
so to them the ends justifies the means
right
so like um yeah that mentality is really
scary
because if you can justify that or
something as
inconsequential as a border crossing
which was regarded as a misdemeanor
regardless
until recently then then
what i mean the slippery slope uh
logical fallacy that conservatives love
to use
could easily be used here which is like
then
what won't you justify if that's
justifiable now the the real counter to
this
is something that i hear all the time
which is well if you
break the law you get separated from
your children i don't see you crying
about that if you were
i don't know drunk driving with your
kids in the back
then you get separated from your child
except
you do have rights in that circumstance
there's a trial
depending on how many offenses that
you've committed uh
prior to that with like your dui you
either
get to go free immediately after your
process uh
in this in this circumstance when you're
an immigrant
the crime is not as significant or as
severe as like
even a repeated dui offense
and you have all of your freedoms
removed all of a sudden
now that changed on the trump
administration as well because uh
trump claims that uh catch and release
programs
would lead to people running away and
never coming up or showing up to their
court dates
even though there's plenty of evidence
to show that
uh the most people the overwhelming
majority of people that had court dates
would still show up
it seems to me that people actually do
think that crossing the border and
starting a life here illegally
is worse than driving drunk
it seems to me that they think that that
is like a really serious crime that
should
should meet that level of punishment i
think the whole crux of their
argument is that i guess in their mind
they think that there's just
million so like i think what's happening
is that they think there's millions and
millions of immigrants coming
and it's not it's not even on a small
scale it's like yes you've got a family
member
oh you've got a kid and and all this but
that that's like the small scale that's
the
micro on the macro level they see it as
a takeover right
i think peop they really see it as like
a immigrant
takeover and it's the but you can kind
of
like i think the problem is that you're
just kind of like a little bit racist
when you have that point of view but i i
don't think they see themselves that way
they
yeah of course a racist will never
admit the term racism is is hard because
like
you know nobody ever sees themselves as
a racist
i mean very few people will just say
like yeah i [ __ ] hate mexicans or
whatever
you know uh no they say they say well
look
you know there's so many immigrants
coming over here and starting families
that
it's changing the fabric and identity of
america
and so to them i think that's how they
justify it and so they do see
this border crossing as this this
heinous crime
and the reason i i'm drawing it all the
way out
i just want to think it all the way
through is that um
there it's just how do you even address
uh something
uh that kind of thinking i mean how do
you even find a common ground when
when the object is you know
white amer i mean why can you say white
america i don't know if that's
if that's accurate because i'm trying to
give them all the benefits american
civic nationalism is really unique in
its properties it's not like as
black and white even though white
supremacy is a significant factor
in american civic nationalism it's not
overtly
white supremacists in the way that you
would understand it i mean after all you
have people like
anders owens for example who literally
engage in
white supremacist racial agitation but
she's a black woman right
um so how do you how do you uh parse
with that if your
world view revolves around black and
white when it comes to these sorts of
issues of racism
i guess they just see them as like sav
like savages and the kind of like
classical otherism right
just yeah they're like look we're
america
we're more evolved we don't want these
people
yeah so that's actually a really good
question
and um you have to ask yourself or
uh rather the people who say these sorts
of things like
why are you so afraid of undocumented
immigrants coming in here
and uh immediately they'll hit two
different talking points one
is crime right undocumented immigrants
are technically you know they're they're
running around raping people
ms-13 gangs they're killing people
they're they're killing and raping
nonstop and that's why they need to be
purged right
and that is not uh that
unfortunately for racists is not uh
something that
uh is reflected in the data there are
people that look into this sort of uh
thing uh including the libertarian
right-wing cato institute that has done
comprehensive
studies on the matter that show that
undocumented immigrants
partially because probably they're just
overtly caught overly cautious to not
get
evicted from the country for no reason
uh are
are less likely to cause uh crimes
they're
they are responsible for a smaller
percentage of the
crimes adjusted per capita by the way
uh with respect to the rest of the
undocumented immigrant population
than natural-born u.s citizens so if
your goal is to eliminate crime
then undocumented citizens is not uh
it's not something that you would tackle
and they change the goal post and say
well technically it's all a crime
because you came over the border well
again that's a cyclical argument
because the conversation that we were
having is like stopping
crime stopping violent crimes that you
originally portrayed
undocumented immigrants is responsible
for it
so um they don't actually call it
i think what they want i kind of really
um
i can tell from my personal experience
coming here on a green card which i know
is different
but like they tell you any little
wrong thing that you do you immediately
get sent back and you
get your green card is removed so i know
when i came here i was like i'm not
touching
anything that could be slightly wrong
like i'm not going to
have one drink and drive or anything
that maybe before i would have thought
i'll have a beer i mean it's illegal but
you don't want to [ __ ] with it yeah you
like you don't want to mess with
anything
but i i can also say anecdotally that
work growing up in california and
working a lot of restaurants
a lot of the undocumented workers that
are there and they're they're so there's
in every restaurant
undocumented worker it's just oh yeah
it's just a thing that happens
i don't know uh i don't really know it's
just a thing that
it's there uh all those people were
super law abiding
and like just kind of family dudes who
were just trying to kind of earn money
and send it back
home hard work but what but but i think
that the
i think the image is that you have a
bunch of um
peop broke people coming in and as you
know
kind of uh the amount of wealth or
desperation right more desperation more
likelihood of crime i think people see
it maybe like that
yeah even though it's it's completely
false so it's like arguing with a flat
earther
uh about you know how the earth is not
flat is it false
is it false that poor poor people are
more uh
poor people yes socioeconomic conditions
are the most significant factor
the likelihood that you will cause crime
so however there
are there are uh there are obviously
different factors and as hello correctly
pointed out i think
being afraid of the law overall or being
over
overly cautious because of your legal
circumstances probably is the real
reason why
undocumented immigrants are less likely
to cause crime now
um the i wanted to hit a second point as
well
because it just doesn't happen so i
don't know how else to address it on top
of that like it just does not happen
it's not
it's less likely to happen unless you
consider a misdemeanor
to be the significant crime that you're
trying to stop which
then we can have an argument about
jaywalking and no one and i mean
absolutely no one would be like we need
to stop jaywalking in this country
this is a significant problem they don't
mean that that's why donald trump always
says
immigrants are rapists he doesn't say
they're jaywalkers right
so um the second problem is cultural as
you mentioned right america's culture
the cultural fabric is shifting the
social fabric is shifting
now that's not a new argument this is an
argument
that uh was advanced against any
significant population group that came
into the country throughout our history
in large numbers uh it was launched
against
asian people it was launched against
polish people irish people
italian people um in the case of
italians they were correct but
but all jokes aside this is not a we
don't like
we'd like italian no no i love italians
i
i went to rutgers so it's like you know
um
i say everyone who's ever lived in the
tri-state is is
technically italian no matter what
you're ethnic you're from like uh
where'd you grow up like new jersey area
or something i grew up in turkey
okay so there's a so i grew up in
istanbul
oh you grew up in uh there you go
my um my mom's family is turkish too so
oh wow dark kids unite turkey's unite
so wait where did you when did you come
to america
i came to america when i was 18 to go to
university of miami
and then i transferred from university
of miami to rutgers
graduated from rutgers burgers in new
jersey okay and that's where you grew a
distaste for the italians
yes it's the guido thing right
it's just uh it's it's called
fredophobia
yeah yeah i got you um so yeah i just uh
i was just fascinated by that comment
but let's uh yeah go ahead
yeah sorry it's it's my fault but as far
as the social fabric goes like
one this is what makes america a
beautiful country it's the mishmash and
the mosaic of all these different
cultures coming together
otherwise it would be bland and
tasteless like british cuisine
you know what i mean like it's just
everything would suck if we didn't have
so many different cultures come here
bring some of the most talented people
here
uh hard-working talented people here and
and try to make this country better
um so that's one and the other argument
as far as culture this is also
documented as well by the third
generation
every single ethnic uh immigrant
population adjusts to american culture
this is a little bit harder to this is a
little bit harder to analyze but
anecdotally you can even recognize that
i mean think about it this way
how many generations removed uh are your
family
ethan like how many how many generations
have you been here
uh my great grandparents were the
were the immigrants so four right
um three no no well well i don't i don't
know how
yeah i guess my grandparents would be
the first right and then my parents so
i'd be third
yeah do you consider yourself american
or wherever
you're here yeah definitely yeah exactly
so
so that's the point is like by the third
by the third generation
my parents for sure by the way also
yeah exactly by the second generation
most people
uh completely assimilate and see
themselves american and assimilate to
american culture
by the third generation it's virtually
indistinguishable it does not matter if
you are
a latino it does not matter if you are
coming
from any ethnic background whatsoever
people assimilate regardless it's a it's
a complete
uh it's a completely made-up
fear-mongering
fear-mongering idea that like immigrants
do not assimilate
and that's why we need to stop them from
coming in or they change the american
culture that's
silly yeah i think one i think that's a
really good point
it is true yeah it's true i think when
people
have this fear of assimilation i think
it really is targeted
or when i think about it it's really
targeted towards
um muslims now right
i think the fact that like their
religion
is different enough to where
they're wearing like uh he jobs
and stuff like this that's also the kind
of thing with the with the jews have
this issue where they're wearing the
kippah i feel like just even this tiny
little signifier makes people feel like
oh you're not
you're not one of us uh but yeah
so but it's kind of so what does that
mean there's data on that as well by the
way if you want me to get into this
yeah what's the data okay so
muslim american and this is probably
going to trigger
the can i give you a warning yeah you
concur
okay he's going to trigger the [ __ ] out
of some people in your audience i know
for a fact
okay um are you ready so according to
uh pew center research
muslims in this country are technically
more progressive than
white evangelical protestants now white
evangelical protestants
are i don't have a problem more radical
yeah that's a more radical sect of
christianity
right yeah but white evangelical
protestants have
infinitely more political power in this
country
than most other groups do i mean think
about it why else are we still having a
conversation around
abortion or gay marriage or any number
of different
issues that are wedge issues that most
americans have decided
uh that is no longer a problem
although abortion being the most i mean
most religious people are anti-abortion
though right
well you can be anti-abortion but still
uh uh
but still recognizing the government
should not have a say in the matter yeah
it should be an option for the people
who are not religious
oh i agree but i'm just saying i think
correct me if i'm wrong
i don't know a lot of like personally
the the stance of
of extremely uh religious
muslims but i would think that and
but i could say this for jews is that
they think it's a it's an abomination to
them it's murder right that's why
that's why the abortion our conversation
is so tricky
because they're like yo that's murder
it's not legal you can't do it but even
in israel
it's a country that's half religious
you can do abortion it's not like it is
like a secular person can go and have an
abortion yeah because when you think of
turkey
and israel you think of them as more
theocratically
focused uh countries which they are
yet here in america that's an issue i
find that interesting
it's yeah it's shocking to me that it's
definitely not an issue that's why i
said white evangelical protestants
make it an issue it's technically not an
issue 75
of the country believe that roe v wade
is a supreme court decision that should
be uphold that allows people to have
especially safe uh first trimester
abortions
um but the real reason why we have this
conversation is the 25 percent that say
no and that 25 happens to be white
evangelical or
white evangelical uh protestant
christians
or rather they are over represented in
the
in the no category but that's what i
mean when i say
while they're only like 30 of the
overall
religious base they represent a a
massive amount of political power
because of the republican party
so their opinions on lgbt for example
the lgbt population
is overall less favorable and less
tolerant
than the entire muslim population in
this country
and this is shocking i know for a lot of
people who are like what
they would never think this like because
they've been conditioned to thinking
like all muslims are super intolerant
but that does not uh that reality
does not exist in the data when you look
at it i actually think
in my experience the um the american
muslim population does seem to be in
general pretty
pretty tolerant and liberal i am like
yeah i mean
you're just one example but i was gonna
ask so you
you are a muslim right well i am a
muslim in the way that like
most secular jews are are jewish like
i i say that i'm i'm culturally muslim
yeah i
i grew up in a muslim family but uh i
don't pray
i don't do anything i even eat pork
which is the cardinal sin
technically yeah yeah
yeah and that's the one big no-no even
even worse than alcohol what's the first
time you ate pork
um first time i ate pork was when i was
younger i don't even remember it wasn't
a big deal
are your parents yeah okay with that
stuff
yeah they're they're my my dad claims
he's muslim but like
he never he's like he was a secular
muslim as well like he was
just very that seems unusual and for
their generation to be secular muslim
is it no not in turkey actually a lot of
a lot in turkey turkey's a secular
country and
uh until aradon who is very similar to
donald trump
and his like 20-plus year regime turkey
used to at the very least have like very
secular areas and still does
uh very secular very progressive areas
within turkey like izumi istanbul
and even ankara i'd say so um
no there's there's a lot of turks who
are not religious at
all and it's mostly someone like erdogan
just like donald trump
using the cloak of religion uh to
galvanize his base of support and doing
all these like symbolic things
because it's very unpopular you i mean i
look you could say whatever you want
about donald trump i'm not here to uh
i'm not even here trying to make
controversial statements or getting
arguments about trump people
but you [ __ ] know donald trump
doesn't give a [ __ ] about christianity
i mean that has been his whole life
womenizing partying
[ __ ] prostitution i immediately think
about like abortion too
oh dude that guy had abortions i'm sure
of it i'm sure
there's no way that donald trump was
involved in having abortions
so how do people buy that i don't know
but yeah yeah i don't understand well
they they not only buy it they love it i
mean they're
like that kind of brings me to one thing
i wanted to talk to you about
which is the popularity of cuanon i mean
people
oh god so wait can we just uh stay on
the turkey topic for a second i'm
curious do you um
do you love that yogurt drink
oh i don't yeah i love i don't know but
this is salty
i love that i can't i can't handle it i
don't like the salty yogurt it's weird
yeah i feel like there aren't that many
like salty drinks
in america or in like western culture
but we have shallow gum too which is
basically pickle juice
like yeah it's like spicy pickle juice
oh my god i feel like you would love
that ethan
i like pickles but i'm not drinking the
juice
it's not exactly like diluted pickle
juice water though it's a little
different but
yeah we have like i mean i don't huge
yeah i like i don't i don't really get
to drink it too much
but yeah yeah where and
how is it that you're very like your
english is
perfect it's
american tv like i i read
english books when i was growing up i
was like i was a weeb for america
okay i was an america booth like that's
part of the reason why it was so easy
for me to assimilate to the culture here
in the past 10 years that i've been here
11 years that i've been here now
because i was just always obsessed with
american culture
watched all that watched as many tv
shows as i possibly could
in turkey yeah and and a lot of your
critics would say you hate america oh of
course i'm not
of course yeah well my critics also say
that i i think 911 was good or something
they're crazy
yeah i looked into all that in
preparation for all this
yeah cancel culture by the way
exclusively a leftist idea
yet for some weird reason republicans
love doing it
and manufacturing outrage yeah there was
some weird
i don't know if but hassan basically was
reacting to something
and he said jokingly that that
america deserved he said [ __ ] it america
deserve 9 11.
yeah but then you went in to explain by
the way do you
clarify it literally immediately after i
was like but you are
saying exactly what we did but did you
know you were [ __ ]
though when you said that because you
said in a video game afterwards
no because everyone was like why did you
say that you're gonna get banned so i
was like what do you mean if you watch
the entire video i go
[ __ ] it dude i'm saying it yeah and then
i i'm like how was anything i'm saying
controversial we literally armed the
same groups
and and caused destabilization in the
region
and then we're shocked when the very
same people that we armed
gave weapons to gave training to turned
around and hit us back
like how is that in any way remotely
controversial right i think i think
that's a totally
i think that's a conversation that takes
place all the time i think it's just the
way you said it
people were like oh here we go we got
this young turk and then you're
associated with the young turks who by
the way alex jones calls the young turds
which i think's hilarious
oh i love alex jones he he apparently
did a a broadcast of that
i've got the video i was hoping to watch
it with you
yeah i'm so happy like i was so i love
alex jones i mean
it's very unfortunate that uh
dudes who are our completely
destroyed public education system in
this country that like people
take him seriously and then literally
act on the psychotic things that he says
and that we can't all we can't all just
appreciate him as like
incredible content because he's
incredible so funny
well here let me perform in part yeah
yeah
so do you think that that's what it is
do you think alex jones is is a
performer do you think
that that he believes that he drinks his
kool-aid
i think he got lost in the sauce at some
point at a certain point
i think originally he had some even
decent takes he was like anti-bush
anti-police state he was like an
old-school right-wing libertarian that
was like actually anti-police
and an anti-surveillance state um
and then he made too much money yeah and
got like lost in his own sauce pretty
much and now he just
follows i think he just walked the path
of
of uh most attention success
money yeah yeah i want to watch this dan
how should i do this the alex jones has
a whole segment about
hassan which i i thought it was so
what did you were you so stoked and you
saw alex did a st
yes it's immediately after the
the thing happened but at the time i
wasn't paying attention to anything
because i was getting
an insane amount of death threats like
more death threats than i've
ever gotten in my entire life and i've
i'm used to getting death threats in my
line of work
oh yeah it was crazy so how do people
how do they deliver the death threats to
you
dm's um doxing phone numbers
uh you know addresses like there's doc
spins with all of my
you know there's doctors out there like
personal information
just like whatever way that you could
yeah whatev whichever way they could
reach you they would
how is it affected
um i think they're like when you when
you get
quote unquote cancelled in that way
because it was so public
it went all the way to tucker carlson
laura ingram's show dan crenshaw was on
laura in the show like
crying about it um because
dude come on you're a purple heart navy
seal you're like literally like
i'm not triggered but he seems so
triggered like you're literally on the
laura ingram show come on you're an
adult
well they were like doing a [ __ ]
twitch broadcast
well because i i saw i watched all that
in in prep
and um he went on the laura ingraham
show
and they were just being they were kind
of being like this guy's triggered
that's the definition of trigger
but like i mean it's just so because the
right you always hear people saying
let's just sit down and have a real
conversation the left just wants to
scream and get triggered and all this
but like really i do think that first of
all
you can't honestly watch that and not
acknowledge that you were making a joke
yeah you're being hyperbolic you're
making a joke i was being hyperbolic
yeah but you were and i didn't mean like
the people deserve to die
no that was so clear that was i'm sorry
but like that was just so clear
and then but then immediately afterwards
you
you explain what you meant and so
if people want to have a i think it
would be way more interesting to
actually just
engage with that argument but to them
you
were just the perfect boogie that's the
perfect sound bite they needed yeah
as well socialist young turks
commentator like
pretty boy look at him he's saying he
hates america and he's admitting it like
we got him
yeah exactly but so you were getting
death threats what was it like uh
proceeding that i mean
did you kind of disappear from the
internet or just keep business as usual
well was that that was so much [ __ ] you
were like in the middle
of the biggest [ __ ] ever i don't think
you can catch more [ __ ]
yeah no the only way that it could have
gotten worse is because
uh they they put it on fox and friends
too and i know donald trump watches
fox and friends so i was like oh no he's
going to tweet about this
i was literally like if he tweets about
this i'm dead like someone will actually
kill me
um if he doesn't tweet about it then
we're good and luckily
holy [ __ ] it got the fox and friends and
it stopped there
and then for weeks and months on end i
was still like i still get [ __ ] for it
all the time
it still gets brought up in any
conversation that i have with like fox
news commentators or pundits or whatever
whenever i go on tv but it doesn't
really matter
overall like and i was suspended from
twitch all of those same free speech
defenders
who always are like wait a minute let's
not
let's not you know d platform this nazi
he has some good ideas let's listen to
what he has to say
like people like david duke and richard
spencer i'm not even talking about like
you know people at the at the edges of
being a nazi
the people who defend all of those guys
were up in arms about trying to get me
deep platformed very quick like they
were
finally not about free speech at all
yeah for you know something as um
something as
it's not like you see significant yeah
it's not even like like
i think anyway i i want to watch this
alex jones
his name is hassan he's funded by
gulf dictators hundreds of millions is
that true
no i love all the claims he makes
without any hesitation
it's just crazy she starts by saying
he's funded by golf
i think that comes from uh the fact that
tyt
at the time worked with al jazeera in
production like they did
stuff for al jazeera but it's like if
bbc approached
byt and we're like can you produce a
video for us like i think we did some
like white glove
production for him or something yeah but
are you even
really you're not as far as i understand
a big part of the young turks or maybe
not even associated i'm not at all
anymore i just have my own
i just do my own thing but at the time i
was a member i was a
host on the network so technically i
guess that's where that comes from
because we because we did like
production for al jazeera but like
funded by
qatari dictators but so i think at this
time
you were on your own no oh you're
waiting no no no this is this is
like immediately after so i was still
there i left uit in january
because twitch was getting too big for
me to handle on
my own while also working for tyt with a
full-time job i was got it i was also
losing my mind at this stage too because
i was doing
two full-time jobs like six hours a day
broadcasting on twitch every single day
and then also working at tyt every day
too it was crazy
yeah it seems you made the right play i
mean
oh yeah let let's let's let's continue
george soros and google oh george soros
and google
okay let's play more than one second
well let me ask you are you funded by
george soros or google
i wish man i wish your apartment doesn't
look like it i'm not there
just to say bash what are you saying
i don't mean that he's just saying like
yeah you could be in a bit you could be
an american
1.5 million christian armenians let me
go back
again yeah let me just start off can we
enjoy the clips yeah i'm sorry let's cut
everything out
ian start over i'm just gonna play it
except for the george soros part and all
that leading up to there okay
all right you're set golf dictators
hundreds of millions
george soros and google he wears jackets
that say
bash fascist i'm sorry i got to stop
again
bash what is wrong with hating fascists
i never i just don't understand that
point bash yeah
as americans yeah yeah i know
i i don't get it and then then and then
they'll say like
antifa is the real is the real fascist
okay then you know bashing the fascists
in that circumstance is all good no
like i don't get it i thought fascism
was like the antithesis of everything
america stood for
yeah but apparently supposed to be it's
supposed to be
okay i'll try not to pause but it's just
kirk they tasted the blood of 1.5
million
christian armenians and they'll taste
man flush again
if they have their way what the should
turn your weapons in
to the nephew of
turd breath sink turds bird breath
hassan pecker
what is he even saying oh he called them
pecker but it's obviously [ __ ]
yeah it's not even like a it's not even
like a turkish sounding last name
yeah normally but still like it's pretty
funny that he
he's going out of his way to
deliberately uh you know mispronounce it
which i love
i just i love all of that
[Laughter]
and are you okay let's continue yeah
make up that name
that's his name hassan picker picker
and if you're a radiolister you can't
see it what's fun he's got his red stars
his antifa flags his communist flags
and he's got his baseball bat and he's
going to call you a fascist
even though he's funded by the nazi
collaborator george soros and he's gonna
attack your daughter like they did out
and are you planning to attack anyone's
daughter
that's my favorite part because he just
reveals
his true fear which i always joke about
which is like immigrants are coming [ __ ]
your daughters like
i mean that's that's that's what he's
worried about he's worried about
uh he's worried about his like daughter
wanting to have sex with me when
she's what is it allowed to when she's
like 18 plus what does it mean that
they're
like i mean if they're so if i mean
they they're intimidated by the they
think that older women want to [ __ ]
these these
they can't compete i mean it almost
sounds like he wants to [ __ ] you
oh yeah no it's great um well the
the reason is like that's what white
genocide comes from right right
and this is again not a very old concept
that's also deeply tied to anti-semitism
as well it's like that
jewish people like george soros are
opening our borders so that
white genocide will happen um that's the
that's the
oldest nazi uh propaganda in the book
and um they think that miscegenation
like race mixing is white genocide
because whiteness is purity in their
minds
so when you taint the blood pool
with non-whites then your white people
are diminishing not good enough even
though they're not supposed to yeah but
his daughter wants it otherwise
right but for him it would be a shame
well maybe
yeah yeah but racist he wants to
well yeah but you know he wants it he
wants to but he just hates that he wants
yeah he wants it i need to control my
urges
he's going to chase women down that's
what he's pushing and
uninterrupted for the young turks
members and
this is the sexy death porn the sexy
terror porn
what
wait he really wants to [ __ ] you dude
now i'm convinced why isn't he making it
so sexual
i don't know but it's awesome sexy death
porn
jesus alex man this guy gets into
some weird [ __ ] in his private life you
know what i mean i guarantee it
oh yeah i could see alex being one of
those people that like
hangs himself and jerks off right to the
point of death
oh for sure autoerotic expectation 100
i mean when he said like he's like i'm
going to eat my neighbors
i'm going to eat your ass
my whole slogan to sexy death porn
that's what it is that's what i do i
have to say for someone so crazy like
him it's really impressive like
that he managed to have like this cool
set
behind him and yeah it's just such a
weird mixture like
it it really is presented like a real
show but he's pretty organized to put it
all together
yeah yeah i don't know and he's got all
these
he ties his conspiracy theories directly
to
merchandise so right like when he talks
about
the frogs uh when he talks about like
fluoride in the water turning frogs gay
then he'll immediately do a quick
shout out to like his uh purifying water
straws that he's selling on his website
for like you know
a [ __ ] 10x up mark so that's how he
makes all the money
is like that's so good he tells you
about how the world is ending
yeah and he sells you the solution
and meanwhile by the way when he's
talking about george soros and all this
anti-semitic [ __ ] and all these
and i got to always deal with all these
people my whole time no matter
anything i do every time we do anything
and make any money it's all about oh
i'm jewish and i'm greedy and meanwhile
alex jones is literally
saying if you don't want to turn gay buy
this
it's like everything he does is to pedal
[ __ ] and
make money oh yeah but somehow
everything any any time i try to make
money it's because i'm jewish
like like i'm the only person that wants
to make money in the world
thank you just anti-semitic tropes
yeah well um
um he he recently got actually the fda
shut him down because he was selling
[ __ ] that cured coronavirus
yeah he was selling toothpaste that uh
cures coronavirus
that's why even though even though it's
fake so i don't know
well how could you know are you selling
toothpaste to cure it
how could you know if you haven't tried
the toothpaste
this is true how dare you accuse him of
selling fake products
and their desperation as america's pulse
comes back and as we stand up against
the tricoms and
defend the second amendment
rediscovering
no he just oh yeah well pecker means
penis i don't know if you know oh i
don't know that
they say you got a little pecker okay
like a little pizza clearly
yeah he's doing a goof but again america
deserves that even goes again to the
sexual
right he's obsessed with you dude alex
wants to [ __ ] you i'm sure of it
oh yeah 11 close quote praises
brave soldier who took representative
crenshaw's eye
i mean yeah if you just heard that you'd
be like wow this guy's crazy
but that's not at all that was a that
was a fun little uh
bit there as well so that was what
actually got me banned from twitch
uh is my statements on that when i was
talking about brave mujahideen
that was a direct reference to ronald
reagan
and exactly what i was talking about
which is the mujahideens
that we armed and some of them turned
into
uh some of them went into the taliban
someone went into al-qaeda
and like that's a direct reference
to ronald reagan-era policy that was at
the heart of my criticism to begin with
and there's that famous rambo three
the famous rambo 3 ending sequence that
says this movie is dedicated to the
brave mujahideen
it is in my mind at least like one of
the perfect representations of how
american
foreign policy always comes back and
bites us in the ass
but it is deliberate i think that it's
on purpose and that's
precisely why uh for example
representative dan crenshaw uh cried
about all of this stuff on
national television on like some of the
most uh watched
news programs on the on the planet
while simultaneously vetoing efforts or
simultaneously
voting no on on
literally arming saudi arabia like
so some of those arms have directly went
back
to the hands of al qaeda why would by
the way of saudi arabia yeah that that's
so why the [ __ ] would you say no to that
yeah
yeah i don't understand that's a
question i want to ask him i don't i
think
one thing i don't understand is how it's
how is it a partisan issue to sell
arms to saudi arabia all [ __ ] places
i mean
were the majority of people who did the
911
uh high just hijackers yes they were
saudi arabia connections to the royal
family as well
yeah i mean what have we taught what are
we talking about here is shouldn't that
be anything like that
engaging in genocide in yemen which uh
even
pewdiepie raised uh funds for recently i
think right
didn't he raise funds for like the the
current janus my ongoing genocide in
yemen he may have he
perpetrated i don't know about that
so how is perpetrated by saudi arabia
with our
weapons maybe you can tell me
obviously they have some justification
you know they they
they whatever they're doing makes sense
to them so i'm trying to give them the
benefit of doubt
how is it that they justify arming saudi
arabia how is it that they think that's
in our national interest oh donald trump
already uh
openly stated it he said do you have 10
billion dollars
if you remember when muhammad bin salman
what about a guy like dan
how does he justify they don't need to
there are there are allies
there are most important allies it
doesn't matter if they're because
ultimately they're just like killing
other muslims so it doesn't really
matter
and they're incredibly important for our
geopolitical interests in the region
and uh despite the fact that a lot of
what we
recognize as like radical islamic terror
or whatever
is directly influenced by wahhabi
extremism which
we propped up as western nations both uh
the uk and
uh the united states of america propped
up in the region
are are all backed by saudi interests so
all those like radical sects
are are being trained and and
given weapons to indirectly by the
united states and directly by saudi
arabia
in most circumstances but it's uh it's a
never-ending cycle of violence that
benefits
the military-industrial complex so it's
good ultimately and also they have oil
they have oil but anyway the meme that
were saying the brave soldiers
is this incredible it's hard it's
actually incredible that this was the
ending sequence of rambo three
it says this film is dedicated to the
brave
muha muhaj muhammadin fighters
and these guys were the guys tell me
about the about the uh
legacy of the muharram gene fighters
they are i'm trying my best they're
they're they're fighter troops in the
in the region and they were fighting
against the ussr at the time
and that's why we armed them because we
we needed them to fight against the ussr
in the region in the cold war era
yeah and then some of them uh became
more
uh some of them decided you know well
america is
bombing the [ __ ] out of us too we'll
[ __ ] them
and and the simplest way to describe it
is that they
uh much like isis and every single other
militant faction
um formed more radical and anti uh
western militant factions with american
training in american arms and then
started fighting
america so it's kind of it's kind of a
a beautiful irony isn't it so that's why
you that's what you meant when you said
the brave
fighters yeah and it would be ironic if
it
i mean it after like the seventh oopsie
you gotta recognize that it's probably
just being done deliberately so that you
can justify
further uh engagement in the region
and further destabilization in the
region because it keeps happening we
keep arming a certain sect
or a certain militant group and this
happens in latin american countries as
well
we arm a certain group that group
becomes even more violent
there's even more destabilization
especially after like bombing campaigns
or
sanctions that kill hundreds of
thousands of people like in iraq
and then that militant group is like
well now it's our territory we can just
take over
and do whatever the [ __ ] we want yeah i
mean and they but they get even more
radical
what happens when you give the craziest
people
military weapons and training and then
just let them do their thing i mean
in a lot of instances it's not even it's
not even
uh directly a consequence of their like
ideology or
islam or whatever it's just it's
literally that they just have no other
options
if you grew up in iraq and
your entire country is bombed in the
[ __ ] your infrastructure is
is eviscerated you have no future
opportunities you have no options
and your family members have been killed
then
then they feel like well this guy who is
a little bit
crazy definitely real crazy uh
you know preaching all this hatred
towards america
maybe he has some good ideas and that's
how they find that's how a lot of people
find themselves
at the precipice of radicalization like
taliban
uh increased its numbers and influence
in afghanistan
after the uh the american invasion
which of course is not that surprising
and that is despite the fact that
the the the american forces there killed
a fuckload of
members and yet their ranks are stronger
than ever and now america is negotiating
with them as a legitimate entity
in the in the country like they are a
powerful and legitimate force now almost
directly as a consequence of american
imperialism and destabilization in the
region how many um
how many iraqis died in that uh
that george bush war
i'm not sure about the exact number
that's always in contention but
paired up with like bill clinton era
onward sanctions
like the immediate sanctions were i
think 500 000 but
uh i'm not entirely sure they say to the
tune of millions
like you don't you don't you don't
understand that
yeah like millions of people died from
that
of course they're gonna be pissed off
i mean what the [ __ ] that's crazy but
are we saying
are we talking about like just generally
from the conflict are we talking about
as a as a direct result of american
military action
um so there's there's direct american
military action that uh
kills people and then there's drone
striking and things like that that also
kill people
some of those casualties are regarded as
like enemy combatants and hostile
there's a distinction to be made between
civilian casualties and enemy
uh like hostile enemy uh uh kills in
combat
but then there's also sanctions so
cutting off
uh cutting off aid or ensuring that
the country can no longer participate in
the global economy
um these are really harmful as well uh
one thing that for example trump did to
iran
uh with the sanctions was during this
coronavirus uh
pandemic iran didn't have access to
medicine that they desperately needed
um and and they could not get it so
anyone that dies
technically is dying as a consequence of
american sanctions in that circumstance
same with iraq
and and the death toll is always in
dispute and it will always be in dispute
because of the distinctions that i just
mentioned so dan how many how many
people died as a direct result of
military
action i'm curious yeah dan i mean
anyone who can just
kind of pull up the number according to
the middle eastern eye by
nafeez ahmed this was four years ago but
landmark research
proves that u.s led war on terrorists
killed as many as two million people but
this is a fraction of western
responsibility for deaths in iraq and
afghanistan over the last two decades
the number yeah the number ranges uh
from
two to four million i mean think about
it this way even american military
like we seven thousand american
troops have died since the beginning of
uh
afghanistan and iraq seven thousand i
mean that's a lot of combat
especially considering how well equipped
and
and uh how well-equipped that they are
out there right i mean
that's a lot of that's a lot of combat
for sure
but what does alex jones think about all
this
oh when you go to a young turds event i
love these
young thirds dude i'm sorry but that
that cracks me up good
problems only viewers but it's the
google set it'll be the google event
so let's hear from mr picker
here he ish his set is amazing yeah
this is so insane
oh hit pause hit pause back it up i
forgot he's real jealous that joe rogan
who by the way is a super libertarian
right winger he just knows how to you
know
survive in l.a i guess really smart guy
that's right because he's as smart as i
ever smarter
he knows all this stuff obsessed with it
he knows more than i do in some cases
and he plays dumb and i've told him to
his face but anyways
he has the congressman on and pecker is
mad that he has this tiny audience so he
thinks well
i'll attack him and say something really
scandalous and then all the meth heads
and child molesters that watch my show
literally methods
yeah that's that's my audience is
methods and child molesters i guess
jeez it's great i'm powerful oh you're
such a big
man hassan
i mean look at the sun's flabby arms
what i bet he's got some big old giant
[ __ ] tits
dude he totally wants to [ __ ] you you
big ass [ __ ] tits
he's like oh yeah i love take that shirt
off let's take that shirt off let me see
those [ __ ] tits maybe maybe suckle on
them real quick real quick
i love it i love diddy on one hand
is trying to do serious political
commentary and then on the other is
saying this guy is big old [ __ ]
a master of his craft yeah that's how i
do it
yeah absolutely yeah absolutely i'm
sorry it's a family show just
just go ahead and roll this okay this is
a family show
oh god help us if there's a family
sitting around watching that's a family
show
like saying that you know uh
my audience's pedophiles and meth heads
or talking about intergalactic
psychic pedophile vampires that's a part
of the family show but
[ __ ] using the word [ __ ] the same fish
that's when it's like oh no
this is this is now rated r
i'd love to see what families gathered
around watching this
[ __ ]
this is so insane
america deserve 9 11 dude i'm saying it
we're there to partner with them we're
not there doing our own thing we're
there partnering and training in a video
game
so he said in a video game right
afterwards
like you it looks like you knew you
[ __ ] up and you're like in a video
game
because everyone was like whoa i can't
believe you said that so as soon as i
saw that it was like
okay in a video game like that for
everything like anything that is
regarded as like controversial or can be
clipped out of context i always say that
it's a meme in and of itself at this
point uh like in order not to avoid
terms of service america deserves 911 in
a video game
this is so ridiculous does it work
uh well i got banned so i don't know no
i don't think
capabilities so that's part of what
we're doing and the other part is just
knowledge
we want to know what's happening we
totally brought it on ourselves dude
holy sh
we did we did in a video game
oh like the armenians deserved because
they were there before the muslims took
over constantinople and then you drove
them into the mountains
but because they were christian they
became still super wealthy because they
were such good people isn't it
interesting how he's all interested in
like genocide and minorities
yeah well first of all what i don't
understand is like
i've never deny the armenian genocide
like i've never denied it but it's the
the most common attack
after the 911 stuff that people launch
against me or it's like
oh yeah shut up armenian genocide and
i'm like what like when
when have i denied it like i've never
denied it as a matter of fact it was so
routine when i first got on twitch
because of all the
annoying little [ __ ] that came in
just to interrupt the broadcast
that we made like a we made like a a a
ticker to figure out how many times in
one broadcast where people would ask and
there's an automatic video that uh that
people would be redirected to to click
on
where he says like the armenian genocide
happened uh
me just saying that so that uh they
would uh understand that i don't deny it
very strange overall though i mean it
doesn't really matter they don't really
care
no they don't care about the genocide
and they they don't care uh
that i have never denied it but whatever
yeah
it's interesting that just the very fact
that you're turkish somehow
uh it somehow discredits anything
you can ever possibly it's like if you
talk to every single german person and
you were like
any any person of like german descent or
any person who's like germany you're
like oh
of course you you're a holocaust and i
think that would be insane that'll be
insane if you were
to just say every single german american
is
is denying the holocaust yeah psychotic
no i agree that would that would just
come off weird and wild but somehow
i guess maybe the difference is that
like the turkish government
correct me if i'm wrong i might be
speaking at a turn but in general i
think
like the turkish government does not
acknowledge that that happened right so
maybe that's why it's difficult
they do not yeah yeah um they don't and
they always redirect
to uh america's genocide they're like
why should we recognize anything when
america never recognizes like the
genocide of the indigenous population
and stuff like that
like it's it's constantly redirected
there's a political
reason for why they don't do it because
then they have to recognize like
uh the the mistreatment and even in some
instances of genocide
of kurdish people like ethnic cleansing
of kurds and things like that so it
would
they're worried about a a slippery slope
in my opinion it's ridiculous they
should
and um and and they have offered
restitution secretly and quietly instead
just
just recognize it but they will never do
it and by the way turkish people get mad
at me even in some instances
like i openly talk about it or they say
like i'm
uh you know i'm i'm compromised i guess
but
so that does it's definitely not a part
of our education like
they certainly talk about
how it's not real and how the western
media lies about it
yeah that's that's pretty sticky for
sure
that's tough so we're so yeah that
discredits everything you ever have to
say
yeah and so you're named after the group
that murdered them and you've got a club
and you say you're coming for us
he just admitted he's a fascist he
literally just said you've got a club
and you said you're coming for us
yeah alex jones is a fascist he just
said it
maybe it's not that big of a revelation
psychopathic worm
we did man we did holy
dude his eye patch is so epic how does
that thing even work
man i do i agree i i totally agree
i think it's like one of those looks
like maybe the the reason why i was more
careless about his
disability uh when i was talking about
it because like that's another point of
contention is like i i
i set some [ __ ] up words that i'm not
gonna repeat now he was like that's
actually what got me banned
but um as veterans uh on twitch are a
protective group and also disability
because i was making light of his
disability but the reason why
i just legitimately thought like
everyone universally agreed that eye
patches make you look
cool but in his respect i've never seen
an eye patch like that like
how is that physically on him i mean he
looks like a [ __ ] video game
character it's
badass bro yeah almost one almost i
think you want to lose as much as
as much as i think uh uh dan curry show
is terrible
i can't deny that that is a [ __ ]
badass eye patch dude
common ground you see it's beautiful
yeah
holy he's so intellectual look at the
way
that this dip is running his mouth he
just called you you just said you have
fat [ __ ] man [ __ ] tits and he's making
fun of you personally
justifying genocide right now
like how how is this how is anything i'm
saying controversial
oh so there you have it uh alex jones
so that part is that part is tested on
twitch because i was that was made for
me to
watch but that's uh that part was
censored by a
fan made edit but that's the part where
i say like the brave mujahideen
skull [ __ ] them and like now even
even after all of that like how do you
not understand that like
war has all of these casualties and
and you're sending so many people to die
and
that's what i mean when i say like you
know six thousand seven thousand
uh men and women have died if you don't
care about the millions of casualties
because you know they're
over there and that's uh that's just war
and why the [ __ ] don't you care about
the trillions of dollars that we spent
and also the thousands of
kids that have [ __ ] died on the
american side even
but they don't and and that's uh very
frustrating
yeah that part about skull [ __ ] is i
was pretty wild but it was obvious to me
that you were just making a tasteless
joke i mean
you know yeah well yeah for sure of
course
uh but that definitely the delivery
wasn't great on that i i would admit
but you know what do you think of
someone like alex jones being
de-platformed then
i'm curious what's your what was your
take on that
i think that um as a polarizing content
creator myself uh especially in the
leftist
uh side of things i'm constantly under
the threat of de-platforming it's always
in the back of my mind as well
it's always something i fear because
oftentimes
um these platforms will these platforms
will go after like
far right figures and then immediately
to be like perfectly balanced they'll go
after
our left individuals as well and i would
be regarded as a far left individual
so this is something i'm i'm constantly
in fear of
but i think that once you
redirect once you deliberately misinform
people over and over again and that's
how you make your money
and then you redirect your hatred
towards like
some of the most marginalized groups and
even in certain instances like have
victims and their families of school
shootings get harassed
yeah by an endless sea of very
well-armed
psychopaths like then unfortunately it's
no longer content that i can appreciate
it does genuinely present a danger to
the public
and um and it's unfortunate because
i love and appreciate alex jones my
subscription notifications
on my stream or alex jones
yeah like and and so i do in short you
are
pro deforming alex jones because you see
him as a threat to public safety
100 yeah now there is an intellectual
argument there of like
well how do we define who is a threat to
public safety
or once you once you concede that some
people can be de-platformed then won't
that happen to you and i
certainly agree with that it can but we
as human beings i believe have the
capability of
looking at each individual case
hopefully
appropriately if you have an idealistic
notion
that like all speech should be free
which no one does
really no one is like technically a free
speech absolutist that would be insane
um even the american constitution has
exceptions
that limit speech like yelling fire in a
crowded theater or
making violent threats or even fighting
words which is a specific carve out
um where where like uh retaliation could
be justified
or some of the words that you uh say
um no one is a free speech absolutist
but but for some reason when it comes to
alex jones or whoever is on your side or
who you feel to be on your side
uh most people end up defending them and
saying like no
uh this person should not be
de-platformed you're being crazy
um but i think that if you are
presenting a
threat to the public and there are
legitimate
there is legitimate harm caused by the
people that follow you because of
directly a consequence of your words
like i think then you either have to
dial it back
and and no longer present a threat
to the public which alex jones does not
seem to be interested in doing
or you get de-platformed did you find it
i guess maybe a lot of people found it
creepy how every they kind of colluded
right like
youtube and twitter and facebook all
dropped him at the same exact time
i didn't think that was creepy i think
that just shows that there was actually
a lot of
thought put into it and they pro and
well to them they see it as
these big companies colluding meeting in
a shadowy room and deciding to squash
somebody
fine i mean if you think that the world
is a comic book
you know well they do i mean look at q
anon they do think the world is a comic
book
yeah there is there maybe there's too
many simpler explanations movies
comic book movies
if you really want to get cancelled
there is there is definitely a there is
definitely a
simpler explanation for this as is um as
is the case for most
grand conspiracy theories that people
come up with and the simple explanation
is
these platforms are very risk-averse
yeah once uh one platform decides to
engage in this kind of uh censorship or
deep platforming
all other ones are like oh thank god
okay we can do it as well and that's why
they coordinated together in that way
yeah i'm not even sure they coordinated
i think it may have and i could be
totally wrong
and maybe maybe it's known what actually
happened i don't know
but i think what happened is probably
someone decided
i think it was facebook or i think it
was facebook that decided to cancel him
first
and then everybody was like saw what was
happening and then followed yeah
yeah i mean companies do this in
oligopolies
uh in a legal way in this way called
price
leadership it's not price fixing per se
if you fix prices in a shadowy room
that's illegal
but if you engage in price leadership
like for example delta airlines decides
to
i don't know add on additional fees for
luggage
then all of the other companies that
also hold a gigantic percentage of the
market share
will follow and will readjust their
prices
so it's technically legal it's it's
similar to how facebook will
ban alex jones and then other companies
will follow suit if they
if they feel the need to do so that's
that's
pretty much what happened here and i
don't think anyone
uh would disagree with me when i say
that there is definitely a monopoly
in the tech space there are plenty of
monopolies in
nearly every vertical that the tech
space operates that's why there was an
anti-trust
a congressional hearing that was held
like a couple weeks ago
um so i'm just excited that
all of these free speech defenders are
now
uh coming to terms with the dangerous uh
power that uh tech monopolies hold over
our communication in
numerous other parts of our lives so i'm
always in favor of
antitrust i'm always in favor of busting
some trust so let's let's get after it
guys
so if we uh if you if we're saying alex
jones
should be d platformed let's say let's
let's step back a little bit and look at
someone let's say like ben shapiro
who has maybe let's say you could
interpret some of the stuff he says as
hateful if you are so inclined
so at what point do you say do you think
ben shapiro should be de-platformed
no you know maybe some people would get
maybe some people would disagree with me
on this
but i think ben shapiro plays
a role in radicalization on the internet
i even think and you guys might disagree
with me on this i think jordan peterson
used to play a significant role in this
uh radicalization on this pipeline what
about joe rogan
um joe rogan as well he uh i think joe
rogan is a lot better
now at uh and a lot more careful now
i don't know why what changed in his
mentality maybe he started watching like
kyle kalinski or numerous other
uh like david pagman and some other like
leftists on youtube
uh and and uh really changed his mind on
the way that he had guests on but i mean
joe rogan had milo yiannopoulos on and
he even had stefan
malnier on or molly me i don't know how
to say his last name whatever
um and and these are people who have
not only worked openly with nazis and
white supremacists and i mean like
nazis and white supremacists literally
like people who call themselves white
supremacists or white nationalists
um or have openly admitted that they
believe that the white race is
superior like stefan did uh in that
famous video where he went to poland joe
would say
um look i think he would say something
like
light or sun sunshine is the best
disinfectant right like let's just talk
conversation is good let's just talk
with anybody about anything right
do you agree with that uh theory
um yes and no so it's kind of like alex
jones uh
i love alex jones i think it's very
entertaining but it gets to a point
where it's dangerous right
and the same conversation exists within
the joe rogan sphere where do i
think that we should shut off
communication from every
like person that's ever associated with
a nazi no of course not
but someone like joe rogan with a
gigantic platform
in my mind is not is not being as
responsible and this is one man's
opinion so uh you know that's just my
personal opinion
but i think someone like joe rogan when
he has someone like uh
stefan malnier on or even gavin
mcguinness on
and doesn't really push back and i'm i
see this as a fan of joe rogan who's
been watching him for years i've met him
i've had conversations with him in the
past when he used to be a young turks
fan
he probably doesn't remember but it
doesn't matter it was very important for
me
to have his [ __ ] mug in my apartment
from like six years ago i was a huge joe
rogan fanboy
and still watch him regularly um but but
i think that
when you're talking to people who are
deliberately uh
deliberately trying to misinform people
and radicalize them
towards the alt-right or uh
towards like really just awful
irrational
uh horrific white supremacist white
nationalist ideas then
you got to be a little bit more
responsible and have
the facts and talking points ready
uh you have to know what their talking
points are so you can accurately and
adequately
address them otherwise uh in
joe rogan is great when he's
interviewing people otherwise you're
just having a polite conversation with
them
and then you're just normalizing their
opinions
or you're even promoting them and that's
difficult platforming
versus like um you know a more
contentious interview
what you've done so far when with your
playing devil's advocate even
like that is a more adequate way of
dealing with that than just having
someone like stephan mulney on and just
being like
yeah that's cool yeah you know
yeah jimmy pull that video up like yeah
is there anyone you can think of that
should be de-platformed that currently
you you're like man i cannot believe
this dude
is allowed to to continue on
not really i mean i guess like
the thing that i cannot comprehend is is
a
keemstar where like he has
he he's done like so much horrible [ __ ]
um and he does associate with uh
people who are
definitely on the side of the nazis but
then portrayed themselves as centrists
from time to time and like podcasts and
things like that that have already been
d
platformed but like
i don't want keemstar to be yeted off
the phase of the planet
although that does sound appealing
personally um
i don't want him to just like be [ __ ]
completely
de-platformed i just want him to stop
being an [ __ ]
do you see what i'm saying i don't
really can though
and well part of the reason why he can't
is because there is never any
there there are never any sort of
there's never like a reason for him to
because he makes money doing this yeah
and he will continue doing it over and
over again because he makes money doing
it
and there's no pushback yeah it's like
there might be some
pushback from people who watch him or
people who say like oh [ __ ] you but
he knows how to dance around that yeah
he turns that into content
in and of itself he has the alex jones
it's like the alex jones syndrome where
he just
he becomes more radical because it's
what
where he finds the most success yeah
profitable
and um but i do think there's a strong
argument that he is a
i think a danger to public safety
i don't think to the same degree as alex
jones who's like
for example sending like i remember the
family of sandy hook
they had to like move and [ __ ] i mean
that's crazy but
um yeah yeah yeah he he's definitely an
interesting case
i mean there's no question that he's a
horrible
person yeah i just like
i don't is he a horrible person i don't
know i mean like
is he a horrible person i mean uh is how
do what are you making
so yeah i think so from my personal
experience with him yes
i can i from my personal experience i
cannot point out another person that has
the same effects as he does on people
and has had on me personally yeah i try
to like
i feel like there's not very many truly
bad people in the world
you know what i mean like just like
you're a bad person so i try to and of
course he would deny that
uh he thinks he's a good person so i
think everyone has the capability of
being good
including keemstar that is at the center
of what i believe i think i believe in
rehabilitation over incarceration
yeah i believe that uh our draconian
opinion on like
our draconian understanding of punitive
measures is uh
is genuinely a significant problem in
the criminal justice system but also
even in these like
i guess quote-unquote witch hunts or uh
or or internet mob mentality uh that
exists
in in cancel culture and all these
things that we talk about but ultimately
at a certain point we gotta recognize
like this dude is not stopping like how
do we get him to stop
like i would much rather be able to have
a conversation with him privately
knowing full well that it's not going to
be like used or weaponized against me
uh in the future but i can't trust that
but and
and be like dude why are you doing this
like there are different ways that you
can still keep making the same money
and even probably get admired by a lot
more people i wish you were
i wish you would stop that's what i have
to say to keemstar
like i feel like i've had that i've had
that conversation with him
and he got super defensive and angry it
was really frustrating it was after the
um
uh whatever it doesn't matter well the
fact that we even had this conversation
now
and and once this gets published is
going to mean that like the crosstails
are back on me keemstar was actually uh
uh played a significant role in the 911
stuff too so whenever he says like
cancel culture is [ __ ]
of course there is like a direct
pipeline from
it was on lsf someone who [ __ ] hates
me immediately published it on lsf
like literally took a clip streamed it
like restreamed the clip so that they
could have it on their own
so i can't delete it publish it on lsat
which is a very
popular uh subreddit uh that
you know features all of these like live
stream files from twitch and stuff
keemstar took it published it every
single like
right-wing uh right-wing commentator on
twitter
highlighted it and was like how the [ __ ]
is this guy still on the platform i
can't believe that they're like
you know letting this dude stay on the
platform blah blah blah and then it went
all the way to tucker crosston's
producers
and then after that it was on the fox
news pipeline so it just circulated
through
but that's how it went like i could
literally track it like
little pings um moving
and and uh the story gaining momentum
and the outrage
building yeah he really has a talent to
amplify yeah he does
[Music]
if someone is having a bad moment he
immediately
immediately is on top of that and making
it 10 times worse
but that's kind of his talent right it's
almost hard to hold him again
hold that against him but he the problem
with keemstar is that there's no filters
there's no self-awareness of thinking
like
this is not necessarily
so important and like the damage it's
gonna do to this person
is way worse than like the actual
importance of me
amplifying this he doesn't have that you
know what i mean
so so the amp he is mr cancel culture
yeah regardless of whatever his personal
opinions are or how he presents himself
on cancel culture he is the number one
chancellor yeah he literally does cancel
culture nonstop
and so do republicans that's why i
always i'm like that's all
i always think it's so silly when when
uh
liberals are the only people that do
cancel culture is like so common on the
internet especially on youtube
which certainly has more right-wing
content creators than
than left-wing right so successfully
monopolized
the marketplace and and this narrative
is is just
something that everyone just universally
agrees on now it feels like
that leftists and liberals are the ones
engaging in cancer culture and certainly
some are
but to think that republicans don't do
it they say
nearly as much it's just because if you
don't outright say
we need to cancel this guy that doesn't
mean that you're not pro-cancel culture
it's what keemstar does every day on his
show
is like trying to [ __ ] ruin people's
lives
i feel like genuinely i mean look how
they've gone after
pokemane that whole saga has been
totally mind-bending to me
like you've saw leafy's here he's made
10 videos on her
and her crime i guess her crime i guess
is that
uh is that he doesn't think she
is worthy of her success she's not
beautiful enough
she's not right she's not beautiful
simultaneously everyone watches her just
for her uh ass right
that that's the funny thing is like
she's not hot but everyone only watches
her for
the way she looks so what i mean even if
let's just accept that that's true
i mean who for so [ __ ] what dude so
so you're
you're bitter that you don't have that
competitive advantage
it's not for me i am capable of saying
yeah pokema's content
not for me i don't get uh you know i i
i don't understand uh like what people
see
i think she's a great person in real
life but
as a as a broadcaster like it's not
something i'm going to tune into but
then
then again i don't really tune in to a
lot of twitch broadcast anyway because
i'm streaming 12 hours a day
but but i can move on because i don't
think that she's like
causing genuine harm against anyone i
don't think she's like out there
like even against conservatives and [ __ ]
she's not even like
even if you were to say she's a liberal
or whatever it's not like she's like
agitating against conservatives being
like conservatives are [ __ ] brain
dead like we need to de-platform them
anything like that
she's just a person who makes uh
youtube videos and a person who like
plays minecraft and stuff
and it's it's like it's it's almost like
it's successful yeah
it's only it's like she became so
successful and now somehow it's her
fault
that people like her you know what i
mean uh
they make it her problem that people
like her but beyond that i
i genuinely think that there's there's
basically like a whole
uh cycle of commentary channels now that
all kind of chew out the same topics
like they find a person to hate and
grind into the ground
and then they move on to another one
just because i think there's interest in
it right
i i i don't think they actually even
believe or care about
the things that they say i think they're
just actually you coined the term i
don't know if you coined the term but i
thought it was good
simp cell oh yeah i did i did say that
yeah stem cells
they're they're farming stem cells so
what they're doing is
there's like a venn diagram of simpson
in cells like
do people actually exist that are simps
people who are just showering people
with endless praise and
money with the express purpose of like
maybe one day they'll recognize me
certainly okay parasocial relationships
are real on the internet
these people certainly exist ultimately
harmless and maybe they even get
frustrated when
uh they find out that their favorite uh
e-celebrity is dating someone else or
has a life outside of
how they present themselves right but
that's not the norm for the most part i
think a lot of people are just watching
and then there are in-cells who are
very agitated at women being able to
farm these
uh simps but it comes from the same
place so
what these guys are doing like leafy is
here and any number of other people that
like
[ __ ] on alinity or [ __ ] on pokeman all
they're doing is
farming simps for themselves
that's awesome that's just like the
greatest acknowledgement
ever it's total seldom
because it's easy like so the way they
say female content creators
make a living is really easy because
they're just showing off their body and
they're being hot
and then they get showered in donations
that's easy
okay you know what else is [ __ ] easy
being like that chick
sucks she's unattractive she's only
successful because she's attractive
saying that on [ __ ] youtube is not
exactly a brave take
and i'm making that video ten times in a
row
because that one video did well
obviously it's great it's actually crazy
it's almost like
i have to say with leafy it's almost
impressive
the fact that he's been able to make 10
videos in a row
on the topic still get like hold
uh up with like people are still
watching them and like
he's pushing like i i i mean he's
basically just testing youtube at this
point yeah i mean
how many people right what aren't they
kids though like i don't think they'd
like
fully grown adult human beings are like
paying attention to this stuff
i would say probably like 15 to maybe
20 at highest yeah i think younger than
15.
no that's scary i hope not
definitely i don't know but then it's
like our reaction itself
our reaction to be like oh that's
actually pretty bad
contributes to their uh their edgy
outlook right like because that's all
that's all it is it's like
i'm edgy i'm trying to be edgy yeah and
when you're [ __ ] 15 you're like
that's cool
that's edgy yeah because you're trying
to find yourself yeah i know i
i've definitely done [ __ ] like that too
like when i was younger
so i i totally get it it's just like
it's like
nihilism it's like nothing matters no
because you you know you
you're young you're invincible you just
it doesn't matter
it's nihilism it really is i find that
to be a kind of a thread a common thread
on the internet in general is that
caring about anything at all
is uh people just make fun of you for
any
anything you care about but meanwhile
they actually don't stand for our
beliefs in
anything at all other than [ __ ] on
people that actually
care to to to say anything substantial
about anything
i would say making 10 videos in a row
about someone like pokemane
that's you care dude maybe you care a
little too much dude
you gotta [ __ ] figure it out but it
works right that's what's crazy
it [ __ ] is working for him so let's
see just like keemstar when he says uh
he hates cancel culture but then
literally exclusively makes money off of
doing cancel culture
that's that's how they make money like
this is how they
and then they're extremely hypocritical
yeah and then i you gotta love keemstar
saying that i invented
uh
yeah no that that's certainly never
which is by the way
the one time i've ever done that and
he's done it dozens of times and still
does it even after making that claim
like he was tagging elizabeth's sponsors
on twitter and [ __ ]
it's like i've done that once in a
situation that i felt was entirely
justified
and he does it actively all the [ __ ]
time
yeah again we it's because we're all
content creators and we're all afraid of
that
happening to us so that's why it's like
that's why because of that it's it's
kind of like an
unwritten rule that you don't [ __ ] up
anybody else's bag because it might come
back to you
as uh moist critical uh pointed out
on his video but at the same time it's
like
well what if you get the [ __ ] sea of
hate from
people like keemstar nonstop who then
also do go after your [ __ ] sponsors
yeah or definitely play a significant
role in your deep platforming or even
uh play a significant role in you losing
your sponsors as a consequence of his
like endless
sea of attention or endless focus uh
[ __ ] on you and finding your worst
moments out of context whatever
somebody somebody made how do you deal
with that then yeah so what
this one guy made a really good point
what was a faze rug's brother who
keemstar
had on a parade of women accusing him of
sexual impropriety and then he goes
he goes dude how am i ever supposed to
get a sponsor
or maybe it was actually sorry it was um
it was ksi's brother
yeah it was dead g he says how am i ever
supposed to get a sponsor
when the first thing that pops up when
you type my name is all this horrible
[ __ ] you say about me
yeah no that's that's the hilarious way
that keemstar
uh is is like very hypocritical on
cancel culture and [ __ ] because he this
is his entire
this is how he makes his money by
[ __ ] on people and
eliminating sponsorship opportunities
for themselves while simultaneously
acting like he is anti-cancer culture
or anti going after people sponsors it's
[ __ ] um
and that's why i'm like if you truly are
fearful of like an innocent person
uh getting their sponsorship removed
then
you should absolutely be against
keemstar
like 100 you should be like what the
[ __ ] dude you do this all the time
that's right you constantly deliberately
misrepresent people's positions
and and misinform your audience and go
after people
and and then you're gonna sit here and
act like you're the only one who doesn't
care about sponsorships uh getting taken
away
well it's refreshing to have this kind
of conversation and just to hear
you also seeing all this stuff that
we're seeing because sometimes it just
feels like no one will talk about it
yeah it's that yeah because people are
afraid that they're gonna come after
them
just like i'm sure that after seeing
this keemstar will come after me as he
has in the past
and say like you [ __ ] suck and he has
he has come after me in the past
successfully and has gotten me
de-platformed which is why i think it's
hilarious when he talks about being
deplatformed or canceled culture
everyone does this i had i have people
i i have you know 15 to 17 000
concurrent live viewers every day at my
peak when i'm streaming
and i talk about polarizing political
concepts and i'm willing to engage
people in discussion all the time
in my chat you can write whatever the
[ __ ] you want and a lot of people will
bait stuff personally to draw like a
to elicit a certain kind of response out
of me just so they can clip it
and then post it and try to get me
banned this is something i have to deal
with on a daily basis
these people are on the right for the
most part they [ __ ] hate me
they're on the right they try to get me
banned they mass report
all the time and and and then they turn
around and act like
they themselves never engage in cancer
culture or hate cancer
or when they're just calling it pro free
speech that they just want to have
productive conversations and stuff but
that that's just that's never the case
that's just never the case yeah i mean
that's been happening to us already all
the time with the podcast
which is that's why yeah i was pretty
surprised by their everyone's reaction
after
ethan going after a sponsor it's like
we've been dealing with this all the
time
people are trying to cancel you every
day pretty much since
just just give them a sound bite that's
going to be a little bit
like extreme and that's it they spam it
to all the sponsors they spam it to
everyone i got to say like
i don't necessarily blame the sponsors
because they're not going to spend the
time to familiarize themselves but like
the people that send the sponsors this
stuff are not even customers
and it's so easy to tell that these
people don't give a [ __ ] about the
product
and they will never care or support that
brand anyway like
yeah they're risk averse they're they're
risky
they have no reason they have no reason
to stick their neck out
no and also like they they're bra it's
branding right so
they present themselves in a completely
unrealistic
way as a brand so in that unrealistic
way
you don't ever want to associate
yourself with someone who has [ __ ] up
because
fuck-ups do not exist in the branding
world yeah right
so that's that's also the other part of
this equation the other part of this
problem is like some people do genuinely
[ __ ] up from time to time
and um i think everyone should be a
little bit more understanding but if you
are
literally routinely doing this and
making money off of it like
please stop yeah please just don't
please just please stop doing it
that's that's what i have to say i know
your time is limited
i want to ask you about one other issue
before i let you go
okay um taylor greene
just won a house seat in georgia who is
a
openly pro cue and on conspiracy
theorist oh yeah okay i was like yeah
yeah yeah
i mean this [ __ ] is like i mean are you
worried about this stuff here let me
pull up this article
i don't know how to say her first name
marjorie marjorie
marjorie marjorie taylor green yes um
so she my god she um here i'll pull up a
video of her
just so you guys can see briefly what
i'm doing okay
this is her she's an elected
representative to the house
i don't know uh how much you guys know
about q he's an anonymous person
all right so um q is a patriot
we know that facebook mom talking about
q and 4chan i mean
what we do not know who q is
okay so now the question is i'm going to
talk about this and
i'm going to tell you i don't know who q
is this is 30 minutes long
because i think it's something worth
listening to and paying attention to
okay and the reason why is because many
of the things
that he has given clues about
and talked about unfortunately can you
imagine this woman on 4chan
as a facebook mom surfing for channels
4chan there's a couple of things that
happened
one of them was when q signs off
he puts three little crosses in a row
three little crosses
and that's how he's signed off now he
signed off with
three crosses in a row um
on november 6th and within a matter of
minutes
president trump in his tweet right after
that on november 6th
he put uh it was seven minutes later
trump
put three little crosses on his tweet
and it was not
it was it was just more than a
coincidence
it was really interesting wow i wonder
how could this
cue know like actually influence donald
trump's tweets
or know what he's gonna tweet that's
epic she's out of her mind
which of course is expected because i
think the republican party has like gone
further and further radicalizing
in the past like 20 30 years especially
um you had the tea party people and now
tea party is
normal it's the norm tea party scenes
yeah the tea party looks normal by
comparison
tea party also astroturf for the koch
brothers by the way
uh and and numerous of their numerous
other like subsidiaries
um that was normalized there's the
freedom caucus now in the house
that's a literal legitimate republican
uh entity that is that is full of tea
party
members and now they're like tea party's
not enough it's actually
a deep state pedophile conspiracy that
only donald trump is fighting against
no one else even if you're a republican
and you find yourself suspiciously
against donald trump on any given issue
then boom you're a pedophile too you're
a pedophile now
everyone's a pedophile i just i find it
so bizarre that
that trump is their their white knight
their savior the dude who just
openly admits to cruising into
uh changing rooms of miss america so he
could see underage girls
changing i mean it's crazy i mean what
the
hell how is donald trump the
anti-pedophile
the guy was on howard stern like 20
times raiding women and just like
being a huge like uh womanizer
well okay well none of that in my mind
none of that i think shows that he's a
pedophile and i don't even
know what that is but but
the funny part about it is like he has
said jeffrey epstein
like he has videos of jeffrey epstein
he's been around jeffrey epstein
jeffrey epstein openly and very famously
recruited off of mar-a-lago virginia
geoffrey who is
one of the most famous victims
and one of the most vocal victims of
jeffrey epstein's horrific crimes
and donald trump has even said at the
time in a vanity fair profile
jeffrey epstein likes them young like i
do yeah great quote you know
there's just there's enough breadcrumbs
there for you to
be like that's a little sus if your
entire world view is shaped around being
skeptical
yeah that like there is a international
conspiracy of
pedophiles then you have to recognize
that it is a little
it is a little suspicious that donald
trump may or may not have known about
this or even said i wish her well
about uh about jizlane maxwell
uh when he found out about it like i
know her i know her from
you know uh palm beach i wish her well
like
all this stuff is not enough for them to
be skeptical of donald trump
i understand why you would think bill
clinton is totally
uh fully knew what what the [ __ ] jeffrey
epstein was doing
i totally get that i think that's that's
that's more than reasonable
to think that bill clinton did some
really sus [ __ ] okay
he's on the flight logs he he knew
i mean sizzling maxwell was in chelsea
clinton's wedding
all this stuff tracks right to make
people freak out
that's crazy yeah like that that
definitely tracked
i mean she also worked with the clinton
foundation too just like maxwell did um
yeah until like 2016 i believe so like
they knew
and they were still working with them
and and did not care i guess
at the very least but how do you not
also
assume like donald trump is partially
kind of uh
in well they say suspicious ground let's
say to say the least and these guys
definitely
don't even need any evidence to declare
someone to pedophile also well
i'm not you look at all this evidence
and say i don't know not donald trump
i'm always
captivated by how the ration
rationalization is
i mean trump said i'm going to read this
12 because it's great he says
i've known jeff for 15 years terrific
guy
he's a lot of fun to be with it's even
said he likes beautiful women as much as
i do
and many of them are on the younger side
no doubt
no doubt about it jeffrey enjoys his
social life i mean what the
[ __ ] kind of statement is even that to
make on record like all these [ __ ]
yeah this guy definitely did not ever
plan to be president that's for sure
but for sure but um
i think they just fight by saying well
he disassociated once
once it all came out yeah no he's a he's
a white hack
uh he's sorry he's a white hat pedophile
like like a white hat hacker he's just
he's one of the good ones he he
intercepted and did a little bit of
pedophilia so that he could uncover the
pedophile ring
that's what that's that's what tracks
that's what makes sense of the minds of
q anon people i guess
i don't know it's it's crazy do
international sex trafficking rings
exist certainly
do i mean 800 000 kids get uh
kids go missing a year or something
crazy like that like it's an insane
number
worldwide okay um there's definitely sex
trafficking there's
i believe there's more slavery now on
the planet than
than there was at the peak of like
chattel slavery it's different
circumstances different
uh uh different conditions but it's
still slavery still very much exists
kidnapping
human trafficking very much exists is
there sexual degeneracy
and perversion all around and like
especially in
in places of uh influence certainly but
like
it's not being operated out of a [ __ ]
a pizza restaurant in washington dc you
know what i mean it's not
well it's not traffic through wayfair
like a drop shipping website where you
could accidentally [ __ ] purchase a
child i guess
like that's silly that's incredibly
silly and there are
say the fact that there's a possibility
that
the clintons knew what he was up to and
still associated with him is kind of
scary because he was the [ __ ]
president and no it is very scary and
hillary clinton
obviously was a secretary of state
super connected um that is kind of
conspiratorial isn't it
yeah no that's the so here's how i
describe conspiracy theories and i talk
about this a lot because i'm fascinated
with conspiracy theories
love alex jones um and jeffrey epstein
is one
of them where i like at least at the
very least entertain
and and definitely think that he
probably did not
uh kill himself and was quote unquote
suicided
yeah but in the overwhelming majority of
uh conspiracy theories
there are far too many moving parts
to hide uh such a vast
and grand conspiracy like flat earthers
they believe that
the earth is flat and uh and the
motivations for it
are really insignificant and weird and
inconsequential like they just want to
hide the truth from you
but then every single scientists uh
you know people who fly planes like just
like anyone
and everyone has to be in on the
conspiracy that's millions
hundreds of millions of people who are
every single day lying to you
and you might have started off with a
grain of
truth or maybe like a shred of
skepticism where it's well deserved when
you think about flat earthers like the
earth feels [ __ ] flat
um you have to suspend your belief in so
many completely reasonable things that
exist in our
everyday existence and the same goes for
all these other contributions like
911 um or or
the jfk assassination there's always
going to be misinformation out there
and we're never going to know what the
full truth of the matter is and that's
what leads people to like
lose their lose their mind usually
like because they don't know this world
this like world changing event happened
and now you don't [ __ ] know you don't
know why it happened and you need to
make sense of the senseless
and there are a lot of these grifters
out there who just give you little
puzzle pieces
it's like religion it helps you
contextualize
something that is um impossible to
contextualize
otherwise and comes across as
meaningless even though it's a really
impactful event
and the human mind works that way where
you're like come on i need a puzzle
piece for this
and that's what q anon does and that's
what all these conspiracy theorists
do i just never thought that it would be
this successful and this quickly
i mean i wonder in a weird way like
fascism is almost like operating by
mainstream conspiracy
i mean look at the propaganda the nazis
peddled is that the jews
have destabilized the world every major
war every destabilizing factor was
backed by the jews i mean
if somebody said that today that would
be held as like
like wow that is [ __ ] out there dude
but they somehow made that a mainstream
belief and so they have different
substitutes for that they say cultural
marxism which is
nearly identical to cultural bolshevism
which is what the nazis used to say
they that that whole like frankfurt
school propaganda
uh anti-semitic propaganda is directly
associated with
more common versions of that that you
can hear from any number of different
uh conservatives not just conspiracy
theorists but conservatives
because it comes from the same place um
they don't openly say it's the jews that
are single-handedly and solely
responsible for it
but they'll just say oh it's the
frankfurt school that is
um you know that is responsible for
our college campuses being so
left-leaning
and uh and they're teaching marxism to
our kids
um it's at the heart of every ideology
and fascism is
just another uh form of that what do you
make of the whole george soros
fascination i mean like
that's that [ __ ] he's a billionaire he's
a weirdo he's he's
a [ __ ] millionaire he just strikes me
as every a very typical billionaire
he makes a lot of money he's a hedge
fund manager he donates a lot of money
to charities
uh he's done some shitty stuff and
that's pretty much [ __ ]
how you describe any billionaire yeah
and
and i think some of that again never
forget
there's always a shred of truth in all
of these conspiracy theories
and that uh that is that's at the heart
of the conspiracy theory that they then
tack on 17 different layers of like
psychopathic nonsense
right so um the heart of the truth of
the george soros matter is a 1998
60 minutes interview where george soros
answers a question about whether or not
he collaborated with nazis in a really
weird way
but he was [ __ ] 14 years old in the
end of the war and he's a holocaust
survivor whose family was
you know his family got killed he was
trying to [ __ ] live they try to
incorrectly
claim including marjorie greene uh that
he collaborated with the nazis
george soros did not collaborate with
the nazis what is it in that 1998
interview
he said something along the lines of do
i don't feel bad
at all about my actions personally
uh during the holocaust and that um
anyone in that situation could have done
exactly the same thing and there's like
one error
with the one uh instance of that
interview where it's like
conflicting but immediately clarifies it
where
um because the interviewer says did you
uh work with nazis to confiscate jewish
properties
he's like no i did not um
but in a way to survive i think uh he
he portrayed himself as as uh not jewish
which many people did at the time
that survived the holocaust and he was
nine years old in the beginning
when the nazi party took power and 14 by
the end of it so it's [ __ ]
ridiculous to assume that he had any
sort of blame for any imagine
regardless as a child can you imagine
how [ __ ] like just evil you have to
be to accuse someone who lived through
the holocaust
at the age of 9 to 13
of collaborating with the nazis when you
were fighting to survive your whole
family was
was exterminated and to now as a man
who's come
so far to accuse him of collaborating
with the nazis i mean that that's like
digging so deep it's so [ __ ] vile i
mean that's just
marjorie green said that by the way she
literally asserted that
uh multiple times among numerous other
psychotic things that she believes in
and now she is uh
is potentially going to be a congress
person very cool
um but yeah it's the george soros stuff
is like
pretty crazy but again the shred of
truth in
every conspiracy theory is that as a
billionaire
he has an immense amount of power just
like every other [ __ ] billionaire
does
but like it's not because he's jewish
it's because he's a [ __ ] billionaire
okay like and that's what every
billionaire does
and now they're like kind of moving away
from george soros even though it's the
heart of every conspiracy theory
regardless but like now they're
attacking bill gates but it's not
because bill gates wants to [ __ ] put
rfid chips in your in your bloodline
through vaccinations
is because he's a billionaire who
absolutely
motivates politicians to act a certain
way
that corresponds to his personal world
worldview or personal ideology or
immediate profits when it comes to
deregulation for example
have you seen buildings so silly
um no i have not is it massive bro
dude you got let me just show you i want
to show you bill gates house before you
leave
uh it's insane bro it's it's the
craziest thing i've ever seen
he goes i remember well i saw him in an
interview once and they scoped they're
asking about like
how he spends his money he goes i'm i'm
for the most part pretty modest i
i splurged on a nice house i'll say that
i just i got myself
a nice house oh dan can you show this to
is it the 154 million dollar yeah yeah
it's mega house
you got to look at this [ __ ] bro that's
not a house that's a campus
nothing yeah exactly it is
um it's it's so crazy
i've never seen anything like it
what are you gonna do with all that yeah
i know it's never him and his family and
they like
it's i mean but there you go i guess
when you're
when you're worth a hundred billion
dollars then
his property taxes are only a million i
mean
sounds like you look at the house my
goodness
just it's so insane this house is really
[ __ ] over the top i mean i have a
nice house
okay so obviously people are gonna say
you think you've got a nice house
you're hypocrite but this is 154 million
dollar
house it's so funny that that mentality
that would criticize you for saying like
someone has a crazy house
um from the eyes of like a random person
who's living in an apartment
even like myself for example having
owning a like a really nice house is
crazy it's wild it's like
a signifier wealth but why the [ __ ]
would i spend time criticizing you for
it
when there are people who could put your
house
inside of their house easily in a lot of
them and they have even a lot more money
than that that's just like a splurging
for them it's like a 50 yeah
of their overall well i mean 154 million
compared to like 100 billion is like
a fraction of a percent yeah it's
nothing and i can't even understand that
number
it's still crazy yeah jeff bezos cruised
into la bought the most expensive house
that's ever been sold
in the city for 150 million
and uh you're like wow that's a lot of
money but then
you realize he's worth like 180 billion
and that that to him is like 13 he had a
13 billion in a single day in the at the
peak of the pandemic yeah
as well so come on dan can you do some
stats for me
were you were you um what dan what
percent of 180 billion
is 150 million uh
let's see how do you even type all now
all those zeros it's a lot of zeros hold
on 180 billion that's what what he's
worth i think about 180 billion
yeah uh
eight percent no way it's eight percent
no the pain is worth 188 uh billion
dollars
it's not eight percent it's an eighth of
a percent maybe
all right let me get on the we gotta we
gotta crunch the numbers here
150 million out of 180 billion right
it's not they're yeah yeah dude
just like think like 150 is a tenth of 1
billion
and you're doing that 180 times oh
i'm sorry it's because my calculator did
the scientific notation
of uh you know exponent negative four
so move the decimal points four over my
bad
okay what so then right so that's yeah
uh
a point zero zero zero eight or
something
yeah i didn't catch that it's such a big
number that the calculator glitched out
at a certain point this goes uh this
changes from
pocket watching uh which is the the more
common form into like a disastrous
outcome
of policy that has allowed this kind of
abundant
wealth accumulation for people who have
so much power if you don't want to even
think about it from the point of view
as like um you know they earned it they
work that hard yeah
uh their money they do whatever they
want with it or
even if you don't want to think about it
from the point of view of like sheer
like because it's not liquid right
it's tied to their properties it's tied
to
their their market value right a lot of
jeff bezos's wealth is
i do like amazon stocks and things like
that
even if you don't want to think about it
as like liquid capital
or or liquid cash pure cash well you
have to comprehend it as is like
power that person had that much power
over uh an in an entire company
a corporation that he himself bit or
built along with
many other people on his side
that uh that now has power over millions
of people's lives
and the example i use when i'm talking
about billionaires
is is monarchies right back in the day
we had theocratic monarchies the king
deserved to be the king because god told
us that he deserved to be the king and
his lineage deserve to be
uh kings as well right why because god
well you can't go against god god exists
and he's telling us that this person has
to be the king
and the reason why people were upset
with monarchies
was because they were not benevolent
even if they portrayed themselves to be
benevolent
they were not benevolent and they had so
much power concentrated in the hands of
the few
there was a lot of wealth concentrated
in their hands and therefore there was a
lot of power concentrated in their hands
now under a capitalist structure of the
economy a capitalist
a way that we have organized our economy
we still have
an insane amount of wealth and power
concentrated in the hands of a few
people
but our justification for that isn't god
now it's meritocracy
well that person worked very hard
because
that person deserves to have that kind
of wealth and
we fail to recognize that having that
kind of wealth and power concentrated in
the hands of
one person comes with a million
different issues
some of which we experience on a daily
basis because
wealth never gets accumulated or never
gets created
alone not jk rowling not jeff bezos
no one has ever been able to make a
billion dollars
on their own it is it is by way of
working with hundreds if not hundreds of
thousands of people it's because of
diversity of
uh of labor and
and uh the way that our the way that our
production lines our supply chains are
are created oftentimes exploding the
the third world countries and developing
nations there are so many people that
factor
into your wealth accumulation that go
completely overlooked
in most circumstances and and that's how
you have
someone like jeff bezos with 100 100
billion dollars
and many people suffering in horrific
conditions around the world
especially even in america what did you
think about andrew
yang's um ideas like
for example that we should get a data
check
in the mail for oh you won't get paid
for your data
mm-hmm you want to get paid for your
data i think that's a
that's a strange weirdly unnecessarily
technocratic approach to it i i think
that
look um you know i think karl marx has
some good ideas and some bad ideas
okay uh he's it's too old
it's 200 years old so obviously like
there's going to be some issues
i think the problem is the way that uh
wealth gets distributed in the way that
we produce commodities
that's i think at the heart of the
problem not like
being paid for our data or not like
having redistributed government programs
that like take some money
shave some of the profits off the top of
these corporations and like try to
redistribute it back to the people
i think that the real problem at the
heart of this
matter it comes from the way that
labor works in this country or on this
planet right now
you work for someone else they take a
big chunk of the additional value that
you produce
and they pocket it in the form of profit
and everyone thinks that that is
completely reasonable i to some degree
understand why that would be reasonable
but i think that we have to be able to
push back
and have some kind of negotiation power
to be able to take some of that profit
and give it back to
the workers who have generated that
profit so your your stance is not
necessarily raising taxes it's more just
increasing uh wages in
in short short-term and long-term goals
yes like my short-term goals are
let's let's change america into norway
let's let's make nor america norway
tomorrow and i think that's pretty
reasonable and that means
more unions higher wages better social
net
higher taxes for the most part actually
what that means i think is is more taxes
on the middle class too
even there would be a higher percentage
of taxes on the middle class as well
but the many benefits that you get from
it
uh would make up for it like even bernie
sanders signature policy with medicare
for all
uh this is a conversation that a lot of
people brought up where they were like
well what the [ __ ] middle class might
get taxed more
yeah but you end up paying nothing when
it comes to health care
you think that's better saving you more
money
oh of course it literally does i mean
this is the
only country that people go bankrupt
right over health
matters yeah that should be wild as well
like a right-wing
think tank published a study to show how
how large of a number how costly
medicare for all would be this was a
coke funded study
that number arrived that number they
arrived at
if medicare for all was implemented in
america was 30
trillion dollars in the next 10 years
that's a crazy amount of money that's
like whoa
30 trillion dollars and then what we
also found out
in that same study hidden was the
current if the current way
continued with obamacare and the
marketized healthcare structure that we
currently have
that would cost america 32 trillion
dollars because of all the out-of-pocket
costs that we're paying
in the next 10 years so right now our
healthcare system is
insanely inflated insanely expensive
and putting it in the hands of a of a
single entity
much like many of these other nations
have been able to successfully do
without
burning uh the entire country into the
ground i don't think anyone thinks that
canada is on fire right now because of
their
uh socialized medicine structure
that's what the suggestion was but it
was too radical for americans is to just
have socialized medicine and you might
have to pay a little bit more
out of pocket if you're in the middle
class not a lot more
but uh the many benefits that you get
like
the the freedom of movement like you're
not going to be afraid you can just
change your job or even lose your job
without the fear that
you're no longer going to be able to pay
for health care and then get you know
bankrupted if you
if you have a [ __ ] nail that you want
to pull out
or or if you stub your toe you can go to
the doctor that sort of thing
that is tremendous i think that's a
worthwhile bargain
and so that's currently what we have in
in
countries like norway so then that's
your phase one what's your what's your
ultimate goal there
i think my i think my ultimate goal is
to
ensure that um there is as little
exploitation as possible uplifting other
nations around the world
um globally at the global level like i
wanna i wanna handle income inequality
and wealth disparity in this country
and then also handle income and wealth
inequality
worldwide do you believe in borders
um in a in a perfect society no of
course not i think it would be i think
we would be much better off if we didn't
have any borders but again
that's not realistic right now and
that's not even realistic in the near
future
so what i believe ideally is yes a
borderless
uh internationalist humane society
but that's not necessarily something we
can do now
you got to raise up the other countries
so that they're all equally
desirable places to live and right now
we have no motivation to do so because
why would we
we want to exploit their glo we want to
exploit the working poor
in indonesia as much as we can to keep
getting
[ __ ] two dollar t-shirts you know
although i guess
if you look at the the global poverty
has that disparity has closed quite a
bit
in the past uh
in the past you know couple decades
right
a lot of that is technological uh
advancements
like technology constantly growing and
constantly developing
does improve people's material
conditions quite a bit
but that's inevitable in most
circumstances unless there's like
complete societal collapse
like it's just a it's just a
never-ending expansion of technology
and and technological achievements and
by the way that's not
tied to the profit motive necessarily if
that was the case then
the ussr would not have been able to
beat us to the
space um in the space race if
that was purely backed by profit motive
you know what i'm saying
or even build like cell phones in the
way that we understand it originally
so hassan in in closing
what have we learned here today that um
pull the guillotine out no
no not at all no i'm kidding
no i no yeah
do you claim that though no i do i
personally look i
i i wonder why i i personally find it
refreshing to see that there's actually
people saying what you're saying
um on the internet you know
i i find that that it's nice to see the
the
that there's more than just conservative
voices out there
and i can't think of many others really
that that have found
such a a strong flourishing community so
i congratulate you on that and i'm happy
to see it
thank you and um i think it's really
cool
i wonder why uh i hope to see you on
like joe rogan sometimes so that like
or something great but i feel like
that's never gonna happen but i wonder
why not
because like i feel like he's gotta even
i don't think joe is intentionally doing
anything
i think he really is a whole a wholesome
dude who just wants to have
conversations with people
but i do think he's there's way more
conservative voices right than liberal
voices it seems like or at least radical
conservatives
and that's that's like kind of changing
now for sure but i think it's just like
who joe
associates with yeah that's just his
personal and even that's changing
yeah even that's actually changing
recently like
um i think that he's really he's really
changed like the the types of people
that he's having on his show
for a lot of issues i've always
respected the fact that he does push
back on certain things though
like for example his personal experience
growing up in poverty
absolutely is the reason why he's so
quick to be like
you're wrong when it comes to someone
like dave rubin saying
well libertarianism could solve all of
our problems
if you know we just had a yelp review
for contractors he's like
no that would never work and the only
reason why he knows that is because
he has grown up in that space and he's
aware of it or the way that he can
accurately talk about how
your socioeconomic condition factors
into your life
choices and it's not just about personal
responsibility
so someone needs to just connect the
dots for him a little bit but he's he's
like nearly there and i think his heart
is in the right place on
yeah he's so popular but
there you have it uh hassan
pecker in the words of alex jones
no [ __ ] you can find him on twitch
you can find him on youtube you can find
them on
twitter but mostly twitch that's where
you're that's where your people yeah
you see i'm live every day on twitch and
youtube
godly hours too how do you stream for 12
hours a day i mean
i have no life i literally just don't
have life i
i like i was no life in it beforehand
anyway
and then look in the beginning of the
pandemic like when we were forcing a
quarantine
i just had nothing and then in the
middle of it my
my dog passed away uh he had cancer yeah
so
this is like the only that's this was
like the only being in my life i'm like
far away from everyone can't see anybody
um and so i just started streaming even
more than i did as a
way to escape you know and like to have
some organization in my life
so that there was something i was doing
every day when i woke up because
otherwise i was like i don't know what
the [ __ ] i would have done
um but yeah that was a big reason why i
was just like streaming
10 12 hours a day and i've just kept it
up
because i enjoy it you seem to be like
the biggest non-non-gaming non-gaming
streamer is that true or maybe maybe
among the top i don't know
i'm not super fast i think i i think i'm
i mean i game too i
i i play variety uh games
so i'm not like i'm not like only one
game i don't play only one game
um i play i'm playing dark souls right
now but some hacker
just corrupted my entire save file which
is what we're trying to preserve
yeah dark souls is like uh like a
multiplayer component so they can invade
your planet
invade your game and then literally just
like
pump you full of like these these like
crazy
items and usually that would brick your
entire game or your save
file in in my situation i alt ford
before he like pumped my entire
inventory full of [ __ ]
but uh now every time i get in to
conflict every time i get into like a
battle in the game
it just says dummy over and over again
spam his dummy on my uh page
dude dark souls is a crazy the whole
multiplayer scene on dark souls is wild
as hell
yeah i love that [ __ ] i'm such a fan of
from software
but it's very frustrating well uh
wish you the best i wish you lots of
luck everybody you know where to find
him
thank you for the conversation i disavow
everything you said
and uh and uh yeah i disavow you
as an islamist thanks
thanks for having me all right dude
thanks for chatting
thank you
[Music]
[ __ ]